boom
hello
I need that right there
and go there
you can also go there
hello
one sec excellent we're good
nope don't need tick tock right now
thank you very much phone
[Music]
hello ninja how are you today
one sec
[Music]
Ninja
let's go with this
what's up y'all
how we doing
[Music]
stop stop
by epi
Becca manual
[Music]
qxt
what up guys fastest I could beat it was
in three days I'm gonna try it I don't
know if this is possible I'm gonna try
for under four hours
um I've never attempted a real speed run
but I do want to learn the real speed
run if that's what it makes if if that
makes sense
um but I'm just gonna do my own
playthrough and try and beat the game as
fast as I can it's not like a real live
stream okay I don't think I need to do
that
putting this up in my mechanic shop the
boys like your stuff mate that is cool
that's good to hear that's awesome
thanks
uh I want to get back into a playthrough
but like you said the sense of Discovery
isn't there anymore see that's kind of
why I want to do this I
to be to be totally honest with you guys
I haven't really played Elden ring in
over a month
I've been in Elden ring with like the
camera mod to get shots for Stuff
and then going in the game to look at
like item descriptions which honestly
everyone can just use the Elden ring
Wiki for it at least it gives you like
what it says in the game
um
but
it's been a while
since I've even played the game which
I'm like you know maybe I need to play
the game to like really play the game
again to like get back in it
you know
whenever I think of playing Elden ring
again I shudder
it's a lot right it's a lot uh no
definitely not five minutes and four
Frost Stomp was completely nerfed into
the ground it's like not even viable
like normally anymore I don't think
no I'm not doing like guys this is not
like a real speed run
uh I just want to beat the game I just
want to play through the game and beat
it as fast I can which I think I can do
Maybe
in less than four hours
Maybe
yeah sub three yeah so I don't I don't
know how to speedrun I would like to
learn it though which is what I'm which
is what I want to do on Twitch
so if you guys uh didn't hear
twitch is allowing uh people to stream
on both platforms which is really cool
um not at the same time so it's really
not that big of a deal and you kind of
could anyway
um
but I want to start streaming on Twitch
like uh actual speedruns of the game and
then over here on YouTube I'd like to or
twitch I want to do like speed runs and
challenge runs
like you know Rune level one
um playing with a certain item or like
with nothing on or whatever it is right
and then on YouTube here like we do
stuff like this like playing through the
games talking about the game lore
hunting things like that does that make
sense so it is cool that you can like
that was a new
announcement that they had
for twitch like you can they're like
yeah sure you can you can stream
wherever you want
like oh cool because I am partnered on
Twitch
uh for
playing I was a rocket league coach for
anyone you didn't know
and we got uh
we've got a lot going on there for a
while
gotta be the same right all right what's
our name
YouTube is for more casual SRS
I would say so yeah it seems like that's
more what you guys are into
all bosses uh all the main ones
I I mean the followers are divided
anyway so it doesn't really matter
Brandon
they're going to be divided no matter
what and it's like two totally different
things
so it's like you can go over there if
you want if not that's fine
you know
I played through Elden ring around three
times
each time has taken longer
because of burnout so you like you'll
play for not as long yeah
I like Lightning McQueen
I can't have it that long let's just be
my queen
mcqueeb McQueen okay
it doesn't really matter what we do huh
I'm gonna use this
and
gotta go with Giga chat
yeah it takes longer because you're
taking breaks yeah that makes sense
uh most people do full on Twitch and
edited stream on YouTube
yeah they do
I don't want to be like everybody else
I'm gonna try I'm just trying it out see
how it goes
you finish Elden ring 60 times my
that's a lot of times
okay let's get it
yeah it's not it's not a real speed run
I just want to see
how fast like can I even beat the game
in one stream I'm not even sure but I
would like to try
the fallen leaves
tell a story you just love the game hey
me too man me too
that's the wrong way
excellent
but uh I'd say I'd say most people are
burnout probably
across the fog
the lands
I'm not skipping the cutscene we don't
get very many cut scenes so I'm not
gonna skip them
yeah I'm gonna get the uh Bloodhounds
Fang
that was called in America theater yeah
is nowhere to be found because I can get
that up to plus nine really fast of the
black knives
Godwin the golden
was first to perish
Godwin the golden
did you drop Dark Souls too soon I ain't
gonna cap with you guys
demigods or
uh Dark Souls 2 is of the a video game
foreign
I am not not a huge fan of that game at
all
shattering
it is a video game from which no all
right guys
oh man
I I can see why people like it I just
don't lead into abundant I just don't
I'm sorry I wanna like it but I just
don't
I was like trying to force myself to
like it and just like right now
you're tarnished
you're dead oh yet live
the call of long lost Grace
speaks to us all
yeah I think it's just a preference
thing like I think it's fine if you like
Dark Souls 2 and it's good for you I I
just don't know
Chieftain of the Badlands
remind me to turn down the game or is it
not that loud
fear the deathbed companion
the loaths
and security and up there
they all know it
you guys really want me to play Dark
Souls 2 again I mean I'll power the [ __ ]
through it but it seemed like there
wasn't a ton of Interest
to be frank with you
the all-knowing
intro is just too [ __ ] cool to skip
yeah that's a good point is if you if
Eldon ring was your first Souls game
going back to all the other ones is kind
of a pain in the ass it really is
it is that's a good point for the Elden
ring
I don't even think Dark Souls 2 is meh
and become I think it's a good game that
I just don't I don't want to play
because it's not
it doesn't feel like a Souls game to me
it feels like an RPG that that's the
best way I can put it guys
for Dark Souls 2. it doesn't feel like a
Souls game it feels much more like an
RPG which a lot of people enjoy
that's good
I love Dark Souls 3 is my favorite that
or bloodborne and then Elden ring
that probably has a lot to do with those
were my first two uh first two games
it's like you you have to use that stat
uh for dodging if you guys didn't know
that about Dark Souls 2 there's a stat
attribute that you can increase called
ADP that literally gives you more frames
when dodging
I think that's a little stupid
but it was a part of the game and you
and you they give you a lot of souls to
level so
that's fine
depends on what you like yeah there's a
literal stat like an attribute level
it's so weird
I should just jump off the edge here huh
I'm gonna try
why not
why not
excellent
no jump
I hate fighting these things
oh
cool stance oh he's gonna do the spinny
Spence yep spinny spins
no bleed yet interesting
oh okay
close
what's your favorite boss in Dark Souls
3 definitely Gale
the last boss of the entire game in the
last DLC I think is the best boss
Gail is incredible
what a great way to end off the Dark
Souls series
yeah I hate I hate fighting those uh
Scions
so hard to tell
ludwigger Gail
that's tough they're close
I'd say
both of those are the best in those
games
right
don't worry tauren my friend played a
little bit of Dark Souls 3 before Alden
ring Finnish Elden ring return to Dark
Souls 3 and said the bosses are worse
than Alden rings I don't know how he
thought that that's weird
yeah I finished Tunisia
great game
that needed more to it but it's a 20
game so it's kind of seek the Eldon ring
mom get the camera the lore guy's gonna
first try the crafted okay dude that
didn't happen
favor boss and Elden ring
um
it's either radon or radagon
I think radagon is an incredible boss
eldenbeast on the other hand
radagon is sick
it's not really a speed run guess
I'm just gonna try and beat the game in
one stream as fast as I can
I would like to learn the speed run
though like a glitchless speed run I'm
not huge on glitches and stuff
that's just me though
yeah
literally and figuratively radagon is
sick
considered sick sure why not
have you thought about any strategies
yeah we're gonna go get the other Uchi
Katana we're gonna level it a bit
and then we're gonna go get Bloodhounds
Fang
and then we're gonna level that to plus
nine
as fast as I can I'm pretty sure I know
how to do that I think
pretty quick relatively quickly
we'll see
malakath is a cool boss fight
I didn't like it when it first came out
anybody else but the more I've played
and fought against malaka the more I
like that fight a lot at first I was
like wow this is kind of ridiculous and
then you realize like oh it's not that
bad
it's not too too crazy
all right do I fight this guy off the
rip yes or no
we don't have to fight him we just don't
we're not prepared for it
but we could give it a try
just one time
Nah if if it's bad
I I won't like get stuck on it all right
foreign
excellent
frame rate
[Music]
oh I'm stuck on a rock
oh I don't have that
that is a problem
he always misses that one if you're like
right next to him
he might bleed here
close
no bleed yet oh God
close one boys
if I gave myself one more FP flask I
might have been okay
what
all right never mind
that that felt so weird like he didn't
even like go in the ground or anything
he just hit me all right
running past
I even have runes
let's go get torrent so we're fast
big speedy
I think we could beat him but let's not
get stuck there already
and then we can come back and beat his
ass in like 10 minutes
okay
it won't be very long
so we're gonna hit this
yeah
no soldier of God fight how many runes
does Soldier of godric give you
excuse me Rick soldier of God
I'm so sorry
[Music]
The Shield hit boxes are a bit strange
but hey
it's okay
yeah 300 wins that worth really anything
I don't think so
hey silly what's up
hi statsny
the real boss fight was the camera all
along isn't that the case with every
single one of those games
all of these games
the camera
kinda
Melina
[Music]
we could technically go to another one
and she'll spawn there as well
I originally thought that Melina only
has this cutscene in this spot but she
can actually be in a lot of spots
nameless King there's nothing really the
camera can get stuck on I think you mean
the be like the beginning part
with the with his Dragon yeah for sure
the camera's a little scuffed there
greetings
Traveler
from Beyond the fall I don't like melna
I forgot she existed halfway through my
first playthrough
I did too I think it I mean
it was like I saw her here maybe one
other time and then all the way to the
capital city is the next time I saw her
and she's like hello old friend and I'm
like are we friends I don't really know
like I haven't uh I don't know
at least that was my first playthrough
she's very sneaky
you guys want a Honda Accord I say that
joke every time we see this
cut scenes I think cut scenes are cool
yeah you can talk to her at the churches
where she talks about Queen America and
stuff yeah or like words from Queen
America which is pretty Neato burrito
do that and then
you guys actually have a Honda Accord
excellent
so this way we can get a golden seed and
we can get
uh some smithing stones and then we'll
go get the other uchigatana uh we'll go
in the mines get some more smithing
Stones we'll level it up a bit
then we're gonna go do blyde's questline
just to help with The Bloodhounds Fang
get that level up our decks and strength
which it scales with
and then we'll be
Gucci
that's my plan I think that's going to
make us pretty strong pretty quick
hold on melanos
Ani
why do people have this discussion of
like which character is better than the
other one
no I don't know why I said that you guys
clearly simp
did I get the golden seed did I just
miss it
actually don't remember
we need to go up here and get these
there you go because feet good answer
good answer
excellent
these runes will matter later
stuff we want
and I was gonna say good enough that's
fine we don't really need another one
you Americans and your feet
I don't have a thing with feet
but a lot of people do
Bank
pay attention to me there we go come
this way
please
please
there's a hole in the ground right there
good
dude come on
there it is
all right let's go over to
the dungeon to get the other Uchi katana
how exactly does she travel with you
Melina
I mean she doesn't really
doesn't really exist
he's like a fragment of a lot of things
not a lot of things but of certain
things
let's go over here
I mean we just started
I'm just going off in game time so 17
minutes
I guess we could beat this boss in here
too I mean why not it gives us runes
right
my headset [ __ ] up I can't hear
anything
I have a new headset coming tomorrow
I'm excited
I gotta
horse hair something Wireless
don't worry about freaking wires anymore
dude
I don't know if we're gonna use summons
I think you guys will make fun of me if
we do so that might not be a thing
what hit me
oh I almost died there's a text on the
screen and you can't like roller
anything
damn
we gotta go this way
a completionist speed run uh
that might be a thing we do in the
future would you guys like that but no
it's just like all the main bosses I'd
say
[Music]
hello I already hit this what am I doing
the sound is throwing me off
this is not good here
a lore run where we don't skip cutscenes
because we're lower people and we like
them right guys
there's my claw grip at work there
excellent
still very fun I just kind of wanted to
play the game last year you know what I
mean
you crafty [ __ ]
[Music]
can't back up into a wall can you
great job guys
let's get some death route
does anyone have an explanation of why
that uh assassin has like three quarters
health
because of my understanding
the
like
uh night of the black knives happen a
long [ __ ] time ago
and
why she would still be injured
you know what I'm saying
from that probably it probably just hurt
from something else
but my brain goes to like still like
hurt in the night of black knives
somehow
but clearly that's not the case
because that happened a long time ago
you think it has to do with the death
route
she stubbed her toe okay gotcha
I actually really want let you guys want
to do Alexander's questline to get The
Shard that can actually really help us
later on that could actually help
[ __ ] it let's do it we gotta do like
Ronnie and blyde's [ __ ] as well so happy
to see you I am hello Alexander I am
gonna skip you
oh we gotta we gotta give it our all
boys
I think it's gonna be three hits
two hits
we're strong
well played good sir well played indeed
why and Beyond this side
so you guys know if a dialogue ends with
laughing it means it's over
Ronnie doesn't laugh too much
which is weird for NPCs
do the carry weight talisman
um where would that be
let's kill this guy for the runes
dog okay there we go
how many that give us I'm pretty sure
this is Stone shards here or smithing
Stones yep
um we're gonna sell these and buy some
off at this guy
sorry
did not mean to scare you buddy oh
excellent
11 of these no I'm selling those no no
we want to purchase them one two three
okay
the great jar NPCs no we're not doing
that
that's like some side thing I've only
done one time
ID
um
do I need to talk to D not really
Neff gives you one
gives you the
gives you a sanctuary song
foreign something
might as well rest
um Do We Fight boat chick
it's runes we want runes let's go
that's what we're going for here
if you really don't get a lot from I
might grab the turtle Talisman over here
as well
all that hit me okay
no shot this chicken bleed right
there's just no way
literal ghost
foreign
nope stop it
actually that's fine they don't even
attack
good
can we watch D spawned yet there he is
just standing right there by the way
I think a lot of people miss this
dialogue right here who won't listen to
radio
it's just another place he lets you
learn where grank is
[Music]
thank you
and then we're gonna go let's get the
turtle Talisman because I think that'll
help us out a bit
we could go get the turtle Shield
I could kinda help
I don't have it
where can I get one
there's one on the bridge through the
turtle shell where I can buy more
smithing stones
do I need to go up here
um no we're gonna go this way
we're gonna go get our physics
Anna sacred uh
here
which we should probably go to collect
this
I mean the turtle shell helps you out a
bit with stamina
but it's not amazing that's for sure
give me give me
got the stick
foreign
good
[Music]
uh we don't really need to talk to melna
right now so
what how what it what is the strength
index requirement for Bloodhounds Fang
it's like 18 each I think
we've got seven levels
get that there start working on that
this should be fine
we're gonna go listen oblide go back to
kale to get the snap we're gonna come
back
because uh blad can pretty much solo
bloodhound
[Music]
and we'll be poggers
18 strength 17 decks it was more
strength huh okay
thank you
Biggie Biggie Biggie can't you see
I can't see
it's dark
we want this
okay that that tripped me out a bit
where am I
don't have the damn map
[Music]
start howling
it's so dark
[ __ ]
I'm lost
oh God
all right we need to go back over here
anyway
at some point to get the deck this
Medallion I could go get it now
I'm also Gonna Change it to daytime
because I [ __ ] can't see we go with
Naga Kiba rivers of blood in the end uh
those got nerfed to like crazy didn't
they so no I'm just gonna use
Bloodhounds Fang
I might as well get it while I'm here
yeah let's get it
although can I get through there very
easily I guess I can just run through
we should be okay
rivers of blood is still good
I'm gonna go with
I'm gonna go with Bloodhound Spang
go go go go go go
I'm speed
I'm gonna ignore this guy okay sick
oh God
yeah bloodhound's Fang is really good
okay
yeah my understanding the nerfed rivers
of blood I thought it was a lot but I
guess not
okay I'll take that
I didn't think they'd let me just tell
you out but here we are
yeah once I level these um
these Uchi katanas up enough we can go
fight Margaret
yeah yeah
three
mostly range damage okay neat
now we go back over her oh you gotta I
think all you have to do is hear it and
then you can ask him about it you don't
have to like be in the area
this way hello Ronnie
sure sure
thank you
how long before the time how long will
be I wonder before the tarnish Tire
obeisance to the two fingers
and I can also that you're not then why
not I am coming give me the snap
the house give me the snap next time
don't fret I just have it thank you
goodbye bye bye all right we're gonna go
back over her and we're gonna go
there just so I don't get lost again
I'm nearing 500 hours soon I've played a
lot I think I'm around that as well dude
it's a lot of
a lot of Elden ring huh
what inning am we going for hmm
can we vote
I was gonna do Ronnie's ending because
it kind of goes with all the things that
I want to get
[Music]
you can do Frenzy
Hood
oh God that's yeah
dude
should we do a
should we do a play through where every
enemy in the game is a bear
but his but is scaled
so like there could be bear of Melania
but it's scaled just like millennia
okay the bear should not be coming here
because I think the Bears are the
hardest thing in the game like I ain't
gonna cap
there we go
because there is a mod where we can make
everything in the game one character one
thing it'd just be [ __ ] bears
everywhere I can offer you
don't underneath okay so he's good on
that now uh we need to go up this way
so
I should have grabbed the map because
I'm a little lost in the sauce right now
let's go this way
yeah revenants would be way worse
will the bear have lifesteal that I'm
not sure on but would be kind of funny
to figure out
we need to talk to uh
stelin as well
we can also grab these runes right here
is there uh an air thing that'll take me
up
leave me alone puppies I just want a few
of these thank you very much
yeah I think I went to the wrong spot we
could
we haven't been invited to the Round
Table
which I guess we could
I wanted to grab this Stone fragment key
over here
or stone fragment stone sword key
because there's a lot of sacred tears in
this area
and then we want to go to the the
merchant
I guess I'll I'll go [ __ ] myself
he's [ __ ] I've literally never been hit
by anything here
almost died
literally almost got Eldon ringed right
there
yeah I don't think we need to bother
with Kenneth do we
uh well do we need to do Kenneth to get
the no we don't we're fine we'll get a
somber before we even ever get near
there hello it was the end of nepheli
and Kenneth's quest line you get a
Sommer smithing Stone which could put
our Bloodhounds Fang to plus 10 but
we'll get that plus nine will carry us
all the way to where we can just grab a
somber so it's fine
swear a good father decided himself
I hate the servants they've since come
my favorites please does Kenneth give
you this golden seed
that might be worth please I don't know
why I'm talking to you we're not doing
you
sorry lady
I'm here for other reasons
what the heck was that
someone just throw a skull down here the
hell
thanks Garrett
more smithing stones
do I have pops
because we need to buy some
I've never seen a skull dislike randomly
fly around
I actually haven't it's kind of weird
okay you I don't know how many I can buy
but
um
I think we have enough ones yeah we're
chill we're chilling we're chilling all
right let's go get our sacred twos
I could go get a golden seed
can I beat you
uh uh I haven't upgraded anything yet so
that's a no
we're gonna go over here we're gonna
come back
I haven't upgraded anything if I
upgraded my swords yes
we absolutely could
it's gonna be a weird map
do you guys think this is the most
boring area in the game
it's my thoughts
What's following me still I don't hear
the music
oh it's the giant obviously
all right you stay down there my guy
yeah he's coming
trying to not the best it's just like uh
it's it's just so mid compared to the
rest of the game
really is
I I go down here to get like the golden
seeds uh the boss in morne Castle the
um
what's he called the Miss begotten
or
lean on
he gives you three 3 800 runes which is
like
nothing
for a boss of an entire area
get it done I mean a lot
okay we're just gonna get the sacred
tears and then
I'm pretty sure level is the only
criteria for being invited to the Round
Table
because usually it's right after you've
eaten Margot
but I've had her invite me before I've
even fought Margaret
so I think it has to do with level or
maybe even just the amount of runes you
have it's weird
I think Lim grave is awesome just this
weeping Peninsula areas it's kind of
like
[Music]
is it number of Grace sites is that what
it is
so if I did go to that church up top
[Music]
I could go there
if you do level one you still get
invited
okay but that I was I meant like uh the
amount of runes you have
that's right
I've been trying to figure it out but if
you guys already got it figured out then
lit
it's a jellyfish
yeah we can't really fight anything yet
I'm just getting this is pretty much the
setup for us to get a plus nine
Bloodhounds Fang really quick
okay I'll go to Caleb because I think
the the last time I played I remember
getting invited in the smoldering Church
which is right in between Lim grave and
Caleb and I was like what
that's how I remember it at least
um
could fight some more for America's uh
sorcios Garcia one of those
that could give us a nice talisman
or radagons
one of the two man one of the two
hey Teflon thank you for the four months
dude I appreciate you dude
dude dude thank you so much
welcome back
hopefully my alerts work
okay so we got everything we can get
here
uh let's go
I mean you guys are saying up by that
smoldering church so let's just go there
and I just forgot about the talisman
[Music]
do you enjoy making videos or streaming
more
um
I like both I'm gonna get this talisman
both are fun
I do like streaming a lot
is Elden ring worth getting chat answer
that question please
hello Turtles
the first one no
yeah absolutely this game is amazing
this this game will give you hundreds of
hours of entertaining content
I petted the dogs in spirit
where's Joy
have you guys seen Joy live on stream
before this like one of my first times
really using a webcam on YouTube
oh we gotta fight this [ __ ]
uh I might ignore her legit if I can
I will say if you're gonna play this
game it's gonna make all the other games
worse
in a lot of ways like annoying ways but
they're still great games
stuff a bit
he can kill me in one hit I know that
pretty sure that's holy damaged negation
which I'm like not crazy about
okay is she gonna pop up here
there she is guys
excellent
forgive me could you put Chad on screen
please testing you you guys want chat on
screen I could do that really quick if
you want we're truly have you if you had
the metal I think it takes up so much
space and arduous path
it seems my worries were unfounded quick
torrent had your measure from the very
start
I don't think it is Bruins pretended
it's just like this area
I can do to offer you guidance I can
take Gathering Gathering Place
let my hand rest
for about a moment
leave us in the basement okay
I just beat Elder ring and started
bloodborne
dude
isn't there a Sony uh
event going on soon
I almost might watch that on stream like
here
for real
oh my [ __ ] isn't working Esther
you weren't right kind of bringing up
your point here reload
uh
all right everybody hold
if I log out it might literally kill
everybody okay
old
uh but what I was saying was they might
announce
something to do with bloodborne at the
next Sony convention
okay
everybody hold
managing
that straight up did nothing
filter
reload
I tested my alerts
old
I'll see if this does anything
members
not soaps
uh this one
where is it
[ __ ] ain't working
YouTube dude all right let's get back to
it
but I'm telling you guys
let's say bloodborne 2 gets announced
I think it might do better
than Eldon ring is that too far of a
stretch to say
that might be a little nuts
and you and you
you
okay we need four more
we could just do that this is fine we're
gonna work with this
yeah so many more people were just
introduced to the souls games
because I I I still think if you go back
after playing Elden ring and you go play
bloodborne I think
um
I think in my head
most of those people might like
bloodborne more
for real
but I think that really depends on the
person and I'm not entirely sure like
all this giant new demographic of Elden
ring players and like what games they'll
like
you know it's really hard to say because
there's so many factors that go into
that
I feel like for nobody you you didn't
like bloodborne that's to in my brain
that's
I already finished thymusia
I uh did the rest of the playthrough on
Twitch
it's a good game I made a Jake's Take on
it
they prefer open world
yeah
in a lot of ways you can it's not open
world bloodborne
Hey sir how are you sir go away
yeah I'm not a huge fan of glitches we
are definitely using Roger
just because he's our boy
Roger's our homie
yep diamesia has a great combat system
great skill tree
upgrade system was awesome just I had no
idea what the [ __ ] was going on in the
story and I didn't care to know aim of
ambition
this game's got a lot of glitches that
they've fixed a lot of them are fixed
and you can't even use anymore
lore open world
buildings I mean bloodborne's lore is
insane it's so good
it's so good
foul tarnished
bouldering with thy Mega Flame
haven't even leveled really anything
yes I have I leveled next in strength
but not healthy
I had no clue where he might go there
I I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
I'm gonna let Roger take some hits here
and we're gonna get in there
let's get it Roger
we're gonna back up he's gonna do some
spinny spins or some [ __ ]
foreign
oh my God that was really close
he's gonna go nuts we got him before he
did
first try
Allison pouch we're gonna go get
Bloodhound Spang now
where can I get a somber one
I know where one is and we need the
runes
so hold on
we need
this game does not give you a lot of
runes
they really don't for how big the game
is
like only the big big bosses give you a
ton of runes
wait there's a summer one at what bridge
where the knights cabin responds this
direction
I was gonna go in the tunnels
and fight the Giant we would annihilate
the Giant and there's a somber one down
there we can get a somber too
from blyde we'll get a somber 3 in the
in the school we get somber four five
six and seven from EG and then we get
eight and nine and Caleb
[Music]
I'm gonna go for the I'm gonna go to the
one where I know where it is
we get runes for it anyway it's chill
and a more regular smithing Stones which
we kind of need for a little bit but
like might as well
you know what I'm saying
wait does he have one through four
I thought he had five six seven
or four five six seven
wait does he only does he really only
give you one through four
I'm I'm tripping aren't I
it's one through four oh [ __ ]
where do I get five from
where do I get four from
I get it from EG where do I get five I
get it in Caleb
I got it my brain's going all over the
[ __ ] place just ignore me honestly
I'll make I'll make mistakes and uh
we'll figure it out
that's not what we want
this game's too [ __ ] big for me to
remember where everything is
yep
yep yep yep yep
give me give me give me you can't shoot
sometimes your words just hypnotize me
for your classy ways up hey at least
when I'm getting this stuff I can save
runes instead of buying them off of EG
you know what I'm saying
where am I going right now I want to go
over there oh
I don't really need the one down here
losing time we're fine
can you imagine having all this
information when we first played the
game like how fast can we really beat
the game
how long were your first flight like how
long did it take you guys to beat the
game
first time through I just [ __ ] pass
right by it because my brain is
distracted
how many hours was like when you started
to a scene at the end
mine was like
48 and that's not even close to enough
to do everything in the game
never found Melania
had to do that New Game Plus
it's crazy okay
you guys had way more hours than I did
first time through
I just missed so much stuff that I just
couldn't find I just didn't find it
I was so focused on the uh progression
of the story
yeah Melania took me hours as well man
it took me a long time to be the link
oh yeah we're decking this guy
oh yeah I can't
foreign
on the way down here right
man's going crazy
that hit me by the way so did that
okay we're good
where's Joy
anyway she'll come down here she'll
burst through the door and be like yo
what up dude
let's go get our Bloodhounds Fang as
well
I'm kind of all over the place right now
could be the Dragon
let's do it I think we can beat the
dragon
all right boys
we
three
nice I'm dead
I'm alive
that's Fringe
thank you
what are you doing
that's not a move I've seen a lot of
foreign
this is not looking great actually
you in terms of the lore for this game I
think my first month
was remembering everybody's names
because they were so similar
quit flying away what are you doing now
you're gonna use fire uh-huh
that's what that big boy
good [ __ ] we're killing it
I think Eldon Beast is technically a
dragon kinda looks like one
[Music]
yeah I'm sure there's uh other ways to
get really strong
I just want to do bloodhounds Fang
I like using that weapon
foreign
he's a space dragon
all right let's have blyde carry us
no life seal Melania would be so much
easier oh yeah
for sure
do you guys think Melania is a verified
or not
The more I've played against like the
more I fought against her the more I'm
like okay this is just a major learning
curve like major major
like more than any other game
besides uh sister Frida in Dark Souls 3
you guys have ever done that
it's pretty nuts
but I I I think it's fair
now
why I need you to carry like I have no
Health my guy thank you
foreign
[Music]
spell Melania wrong I mean
how are they spelling it
yeah I always think of male Nia
blind's a homie give me my uh somber 2
please
I'm not learning how to spell her name
good point good point
okay so we need a three
let's go upgrade I I think I got this
let's go upgrade our uchis we're gonna
go beat godric we're gonna get the runes
we're gonna get the great Rune we're
gonna go and buy three and four from EG
we're gonna go get five
can we beat
godskin Noble
we don't need to buy three we're gonna
buy four from EG we're gonna save a
bunch of runes here guys
I got it I'm not even gonna tell you
what I'm doing I got it in my brain
it might be wrong but we're still gonna
do it my game crashed
I'm I'm moving too quickly for the game
I'm flying
no
what the heck
I am moving way too quick for this game
right now
man
well
I mean it's not crashing hello
oh
there we whoa whoa
White
there we go
yeah I am close to five hundred dollars
player
man dude
hey what other games do you guys play
besides Elven ring
what guys are you playing what games are
you playing right now
that was a literal flashbang
milk
there's other games
exactly there are
foreign
nice
I haven't played Kirby in a while
earlier uh yeah might go back to sakiro
I played Sakira about a month ago and
had a good time
you just started Elden ring have fun man
I wish I could erase my memory and play
this game again
Shin Dark Souls 3
halt of the Lamb I'm not what is called
of the Lamb is that another like Souls
like or is it totally different
bloodborne we need to do that I'm you
know why we haven't played bloodborne on
stream yet
is because I'm sort of waiting for a 60
frames update a remaster
or like another
uh announcement for it well
yeah your arms then
okay that should be enough
oh we need twos
two at all okay
we are gonna level we're gonna level
we're gonna level up
uh wait
that first should I just get these to
20. no I need more health
guys what was the requirements again I
could literally look
I could literally like
and not have you guys do everything for
me
all right
18 strength 17 decks thank you thank you
teen strength 17 decks
bigger for the rest because we need that
[ __ ] all right
now
fix that [ __ ] who's this enhances charge
attacks
sure sure
and
let's go beat up godric
we got the requirements
do you guys know that the serpents
hunter that you get from the Reichard
boss room requires nothing
which is why it's used in the speed runs
that could be fun
I will get Miyazaki any feet if he makes
bloodborne PC
I will
oh to go back in what we were talking
about earlier if when is when is the
PlayStation uh
event thing
we could watch that on stream I think
that would be fun
and we'd pretty much be sitting there
like just waiting for any announcement
about
any of this stuff
well we could also look at the other
stuff that would be fun
wow but of course
okay
Elden ring needs more feet they they got
a lot of feet in the game man like if
you need more feet
you might have a feet thing
I did not think that came in that fast
came in hot
winner
what is happening holy [ __ ] I've
literally never been hit by those things
we're fine
the more God has a big feet they're big
and hairy
imagine if the fingers were toes
would you guys like the game even more
big hairy toes sticking up out of the
ground
or just alive [ __ ] weird
I'm trying boot it I'm going as fast as
I can
and hello how are you
Elden toes
ranalia
yeah I don't I don't know why people get
so upset when people
things wrong
and pronounce things wrong
in my brain I'm like you know what I'm
talking about
on your titties you know what I'm saying
like kind of kind of chill
so I guess everything is just gonna
[ __ ] hit you
I am also magnificent
thank you for asking as well
[Music]
yeah I make my own thumbnails
bum sakiro over Elden ring
that's what you think sure
stop spamming it though you're gonna get
in trouble
saying
calm down
I hate you
I hate birds
I'm done it's over
that doesn't kill you
I love fighting birds man they're so
much fun I love fighting the birds
the birds are great
not at all Annoying Annoying to fight
it's a great time all around
all right let's get into felly in here
to help us even though she really
doesn't really like help that much but
like you know it is what it is
if I ask you call the winds run I'm
certain are you going for a record no
I'll pass a fellow I'm just playing
through the game I wanted to play the
game today
but I'm gonna play it as fast as I can
life is bird oh God
why I increase my up either I don't know
either
Bloodhound Spang build
those strengthen decks
hey I love Sakura it's just totally
different from this game
um booted
do you know what I'm thinking
you got that vibe
I'm just getting a vibe
you know what I'm saying yeah I'm gonna
do it in one stream I'm gonna stream
until I beat the game
true born air yeah a chill fast run hey
guys
oh Kindred and we watch cutscenes
guys press one if we should ban garak
the sock whatever your name is
you can either calm down and stop being
annoying or you're gonna get banned
I command thee now
I am I'm just saying everybody wants to
ban you you're being annoying and you
know it don't give me the come on man
you know what you're doing calm down
let's go I did not get in a felony did I
I did not get in a Philly
that's fine
I got completely distracted by the fact
we did not have been felly that's my bad
I just I just love her
godric is
quite easy although when you don't have
a lot of Health like I don't right now
it can be kind of hard
[Music]
foreign
you can come and help anytime
that'd be sick
lead there it is
thank you
[Music]
she's there for moral support
perfect
isn't it amazing when somebody gets
weird and toxic that like one or two
others just like come out of nowhere and
do the exact same thing
it's like
[ __ ] relaxed
she's not the best in this fight
thank you
[Music]
you know if you die to him in this stage
he goes
great Godfrey did thou's Witness
wow trigger
oh this is gonna hit me
you just do a spin nice
it's all over the place
I I rolled the wrong way
we got it on this one
go go go go
the felly common uh help for moral
support as as you were doing as you were
as you were
hahaha
I hate that attack it comes out of
nowhere and it like always hits me
the wind attack
oh I don't like this
yes we will be doing all the demigods
thank you
100 Elder ring is worth it uh
yes except for the dungeons
I wouldn't say the dungeons are really
all that great
oh I just died awesome
you know what the belly does have is a
lot of help
nice
get him get him
what a stud
oh God I'm dead
it's over this
noveli I think you could kill him
let's let nepheli get the kill
uh
come on the felly you can do it there we
go
see she just had to get eaten real quick
and burned alive but she's fine
that's a good point stranger
this one right here
fruit
you're buying a felly thanks
uh
bless me
all right now
do we kill him or not
yesterday
or do I punch him
craving to the boat we'll just do that
that seems fine
let's shut him up
we'll punch him we'll punch him we'll
punch him all right let's go get our uh
great room and then we will
go to EG because we no we have to go to
the
we have to go to the school first
which we can
and then
we'll go to EG buy the four
we'll go to caled get the five
we have to go to volcano Manor
actually we can get the five and Caleb
we can get the five six and seven in
volcano Manor by going to the school
out
that hurt my soul
We're not gonna do Euro
not super worth
do you have a favorite build I would say
the one we're doing which is strength
decks Bloodhound Spang
I'd say
my personal favorite
a dang
what's your favorite build
yeah it doesn't really go with what
we're doing Krista
foreign
I agree
Amit azuru
actually like the zyhander
it's wildhander however you say it when
we did the god of Rick in the 100 run
that was actually really fun
the uh
uh it's strength index that scales with
the Bloodhound Spang so we'll do that
excellent
now we can go
um we gotta go to school so let's go to
school
it does have a nice crotch book
you know what one thing I really still
haven't done
in this game
is uh I have not done PVP
I have had no interest in the PVP at all
is that weird
it's not a PVP guy
it's not a huge not huge on it
[Music]
oh you made that yeah the town and
rivers of blood are you made a Nerf
bloodhound
and rivers of blood I know they nerfed
rivers of blood but I think Bloodhound
is still they've nerfed Bloodhounds step
and thank you for the two dollars I
appreciate that
um I'm using Bloodhounds Fang which has
a different Ash of War
PVP is fun I heard it's way better now
haven't uh I haven't touched it yet
okay let's level up a little bit let's
get that to like 20
uh we'll just go with bigger for now
just so we're not like dying as fast
hello eyeball lady do we do hayata
ayetta
uh
uh we don't have to so we're not going
to
if you guys want a full questline play
through there's a there's a playlist on
my channel of the entire game in all of
the quest lines
that's not what we're doing
today
it doesn't interest you at all it's fun
depending on Lobby 3v1s can be annoying
only one certain people just aren't
spamming spells and Ashes can be really
fun
okay maybe I just haven't given it
enough of a
favorite boss uh just overall
radon
radon I know he's like actually really
easy now but I still think that's just
an epic fight it's my fave
May chaos take the world yeah what
ending do you guys want
because we could do that all we gotta do
is get down in the sewers and we got
that's an ending
yes we will do Ronnie's questline mainly
because we are gonna kill Estelle
I would say Estelle is a major boss
yes Leonard is also
margate's a great fight too
for real is it is a great fight that's
very very good point
yeah
just protect myself from these crazy
people
Melania are Godfrey there's a lot of
good fights in this game I know there's
a lot of reuse bosses but a lot of the
main bosses in this game are
actually really [ __ ] cool like really
really cool
actually
let's get it let's get it let's get it
we gotta get the key
I could try and kill the dragon
we can kill the dragon
I'm gonna uh change my flask so I have
two FP flasks
are people actually have said at the
ReUse bosses yes they are
I'm not I'm not in that boat that
doesn't upset me it's an open world game
I think it's gonna be a thing I think
they kind of changed it around enough
for it to be really not even a factor
uh and put them in places that make
sense
for the most part uh but I I don't see
that as a bad thing
[Music]
allocate let's do that just so I have
more of these
uh because this Dragon might actually
[ __ ] me up like no cap
they might [ __ ] me up
oh we could sneak
of course
you're gonna step on you
no
what's up
just fire use fire use fire use fire
[ __ ] you
what is this [ __ ]
what's up catington
what up send you
kindness
foreign
get the bleed and this
very nice Papa blue
Papa blue
foreign
enough away he might use fire which
would be cool nice
you can't get to there you can only get
from them
foreign
dang it
[Music]
this is why we got the other balloon
for this situation
hi Sinister
surprise he hasn't staggered
I don't want to risk it
that was actually like perfect that
could not have been better
that went as good as it could and now we
can afford uh the stuff from EG
which we only need the four
which
I'm just gonna go hit his thing then
we're gonna go to school
we're gonna get the three we're gonna go
get the four
we're gonna go back to the school we're
gonna teleport the volcano Manor
we're gonna get the five the six and the
Seven
and we'll get that eight and the nine
from Caleb
I didn't get the key did I
did I not get the key
I didn't the fight ended up so far away
thinking ahead thinking ahead thinking
ahead
I am speed I thought media of whatever
the dragon in Dark Souls 3 DLC was
called he made me love Elder and Dragons
more
oh midir yeah Madeira is
I my mic is making me I can't do the
chef's kiss
there we go
my dear is so [ __ ] good
no we haven't even been to Caleb yet
okay and then we're gonna see
like
you like that
yeah it's it's perfect game we should
play uh
you guys want to play Dark Souls 3 on
stream one day
we could I love that game I have 1500
hours in that game man I love Dark Souls
3.
I would say mid-year is the
um is Madeira the toughest boss in Dark
Souls 3
there's ways to make him really easy
um but if you don't know what those I
would say sister Frida is the hardest
one at least for me
I think sister Frieda is the hardest one
I find Gail to not be that hard it it
must just be a play style thing
all bosses of Dark Souls 3 yeah
of this snow we're just we're gonna do
all the main bosses but not all the
bosses
the S2 is your favorite overall dude I
tried man I I can't I literally can't
it's so
it's just not my style man I'm sorry I
don't like Dark Souls 2. I tried to like
it I just don't
but if you like it good for you enjoy it
that's fine
all the power to you
it's not my cup of tea
here
yeah I think everyone should try Dark
Souls 2 like maybe you'll like it I just
I just don't
okay now let's go back to the school
it's your first one
I think uh everyone's first Souls game
is probably their favorite wouldn't you
say
okay since we have to go through the
school
all I'm trying to get is there so
I'm not gonna level or anything yet
we'll come back to the school and kill
Ronaldo once we get our Bloodhounds Fang
up a bit
did you enjoy Dark Souls 1 yes I think
Dark Souls 1 is one of the best games
ever
is it my favorite Souls game no but it
is an amazing game
I I really really like it
but it's not my favorite
oh yeah compared to Elden ring all the
other games are pretty slow they they
really are this they turn the enemy boss
speed in this game up to like
double
eldering's hard
but
um I'd say sakiro's a bit faster maybe
in a lot of ways in a few ways
bloodborne as well
uh
you know they all have their different
speeds
love secure is a I love all the from
software games
for Dark Souls 2 for me
but again that's that's me
but sakiro I would say is
uh
like a rhythm game you know
it's like a rhythm game
you learn the patterns of The rhythms of
when each boss is attacking you so that
you can deflect and attack at the
encounter attack
it's awesome
bloodborne's more about aggression
because you get health back like let's
say you lose a little bit of Health when
you're attacked by a boss and then if
you attack the boss or the enemy it
could be any game any enemy not just the
boss but
um
get out of here you'll get health back
which obviously you know
makes you want to play aggressive
you're kind of a thick boy huh
[Music]
foreign
now
is that all I needed I'm just thinking
ahead
because once we get a volcano Manor we
can't leave so we gotta make sure we're
upgraded enough to go there uh
yep I get the four from EG
we just need the four and then we'll go
upgrade it
took you a couple of goes
I have a really like the ash bore on
this is kind of insane I Brazil
I like how he just stops talking to you
there for a second he's like oh a
tarnished I presume back to my [ __ ]
book [ __ ] I think I care yeah
you strengthen my [ __ ]
you one two three four
that's poggers
Foggers in the chat if you know what
that is
plus four weapon is good
we go fast
we go hard I don't think I've used nope
there we go
more man does Speed Run yeah kind of a
speed run
now we're gonna level a bit
get us even stronger
so
17 317 bang bang bang bang
um
let's do that I think our endurance is a
little low
now
we need a five
which we get from volcano Manor we could
uh we can be Ronaldo
I should have got the I'm an idiot I
should have got the other uh resting
spot in the school in the classroom
that would have been easier
all right let's get it let's beat
Ronaldo get the runes level up more
we'll go to volcano Manor we'll beat the
noble
will beat Reichard
get all the runes from that
level up even more
uh we get five six and seven in volcano
Manor the saundersmithing stones
five and eight or eight nine and Caleb
and then we're pretty much got A plus
nine weapon to kind of run through
the rest of the game
we'll still need to level it but
like level our character but we should
be good
bye bye doggy oh
hold on one second
okay cool
yep time for this uh
you guys like this boss
I should go get the uh Source seals as
well that actually are like pretty good
talismans for this
this boss can be a pain in the ass
really can
what are trainers oh that's cool I like
that that ever but I like it
[Music]
foreign
that was fast holy [ __ ]
we're actually yeah this this is working
pretty good we're strong
we're strong as [ __ ]
you
there
kind of need more FP this is fine
non-to renala
you one shot the dog
the field versions gave you more trouble
interesting how many of those dogs are
there
three
four three
this is a plus four right now we're
trying to get it to plus nine
um I'm not fighting this guy we're gonna
cheese the [ __ ] out of him
if it works
there we go
the man dropped down on my head dude
what the heck
wow all right thanks man
jump attack on me
oh I didn't rest
this it's it's it's Ronaldo we should be
okay
there's four of them
we gonna do four to sacks we can
her her Thea's quest line is pretty
quick ish kinda and it kind of goes with
Ronnie's quest line so we can yeah we
can do four to six
this creeped me out
so [ __ ] much
first time seeing this
[Music]
we did talk about how many
hmm
all remembrance the song okay
we'll try we'll see
I'll soon I would like to do all
remembrances speed runs like legit ones
well we're not just kind of chilling
and I also want to do a rune level one I
think I'll do those runs and practice
them on Twitch
so there's a link to my Twitch in the
description if you guys are interested
in that
like I'll probably stream on Twitch
tonight as well
[Music]
did
berries aren't believed not enough to
unforge
me time
[Music]
I like how she just takes her children
and uses them to bling [ __ ] at us
I don't want to die to the chandelier
[Music]
I hear you okay
[Music]
we're in level one is the serpent Hunter
spear
yeah isn't that what um the speedrunners
are using
does anyone feel bad for Ronaldo I
beloved like her her lore I should do a
video on Ronaldo he's like I feel bad
for her
mainly
like she pretty much just got kind of
[ __ ]
and and she's so heartbroken that she
like lost her mind it's so sad
upon my name because he kind of like
dropped everything for her and then just
left her
It's gotta be a mind [ __ ] you know
yeah
right she turns him into tombstones
they're her children in that attack that
I got hit by
eight yep we're gonna roll this combat
as they're actually gonna run up to her
and not even roll of the last queen
did Rad daddy Ruiner on purpose though
like to incite War I don't know
that's a good question
I mean think of like Hey we're gonna
call upon you to be the next Eldon Lord
what do you do also do we know if
radagon in America were the same person
at that time
maybe it was America who did it
and it wasn't even up to radagon
poor little Ronnie dude I'm trying to
look at Ronaldo
because she can kill me in one hit guys
all right she's doing her thing where
she's just spamming summons
we have one more Health this is great
because I had to use one on the [ __ ]
dog
[Music]
dude
foreign
[Music]
get [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
almost died good [ __ ]
close one
we're not mistaken the current world
record for Elden ring speedrun is a
little bit less than three minutes and
you'd be right
the world record for this game is under
three minutes and it requires a
ridiculous amount of glitches
which I'm not a big fan of you're not
even like playing the game at that point
you know
pop not that this
we're gonna level enough to beat the
godskin noble
which
how many levels do we have seven let's
get five into that honestly and then put
two into these
um I'm gonna go get this uh where was
that
it's all the way down here
it's right here we're gonna go get
another talisman
yeah you just skip the whole game with
uh some a glitch called zipping
like your character just goes we
cross the whole [ __ ] map
oh wait why would I use this one when I
can get the one in Caleb
yeah that'd be a little dumb
59 minutes for glitchless that that one
right there is the one I would like to
practice
a glitchless speedrun I would really
like to learn that one
where am I going we need to go this way
um do you not like spells I hardly see
you spells no not really I don't I don't
use a ton of spells I like uh
swords things like that
yeah we're gonna do volcano Manor to get
uh five six and seven upgrade
which I could grab
five six well I can't upgrade it because
you can't leave the thing about this is
that you cannot leave volcano Manor
if I get there the way that I'm gonna
get there
um
and you like you can't yeah you can't
leave I couldn't leave to go upgrade so
I have to make sure when I go there that
we're good
that we can beat the godskin noble
because I I find Reichard to be easier
than the godskin noble
is there another turtle Talisman here
just get the grace and rest where's the
grace
I could grab the five that's actually
here let's do that
it's in the swamp over here
I'm not gonna use sleep no
use this
I also might buy that
um
some different armor
fun
but if I go there by being transported
by the
adjudicator what is it called
the big metal dudes that grab you
and I transport there there's nowhere to
rest unless you beat the godskin noble
to my understanding
gonna kill the grail for the runes
sounds really boring
but we could
virgins
right I think they're adjudicators
you have armor right no you're a
different one
foreign
where's that little hole in the wall
because there is a five banger
it's over here
he had called virgin
ah Caleb
we love Caleb right guys
hopefully
foreign
is this the sobber 5 oh well I could
have just not done that excellent
what else can we do while we're here
what else can we do we can get the eight
and the nine while we're here I guess
[ __ ] it
why is there no lore on the things that
the stone clumps
is there no lore on it
it's got to be something out there
why am I tripping yeah there we go okay
okay did we kill Redan before Reichard
because I think we could
but we'd have to trigger the quest line
to even have radon start his Festival
that is what selin turns into yes
do we know the you know the purple Mist
it was just emitting toward me
is that like the sleep stuff because it
just hurts me
it looks like the sleep stuff
might not be
[ __ ] you Gideon
there's our eight banger
you guys do we want to kill the the big
dragon Grail did we do that
it's a hundred thousand runes or like
something like that it's like a hundred
and something
and then a Nine's down here
there's our nine
so we need a six and a seven that's it
um we want to go up to the Fort up there
to get the sore seal
scar seal
whichever one
it's 80.
I could have killed gostock and got a
thing that'll give us more wounds when
we kill it
I don't think it's really necessary to
kill him like a hundred thousand isn't
gonna do
anything crazy honestly Bonk
move
three
oh and we can get the other uh ductus
medallion
that's the other reason we should go
here not where I'm going over here
yep sore seal and ductus Medallion is
what we're going for here
looks like a big scary ass [ __ ]
Dragon to me
I really hope in a future DLC that we
can see Khalid
before the Scarlet rod
I think that'd be cool
I would imagine it just looks more like
the Mist wood
okay there's our deck this
oh I need to equip godric's great room
too that'll help us out as well
oh God
foreign
feels good man
get me the [ __ ] out of here
y'all have no idea how like what I just
did
y'all got no clue
actually you probably do
I don't know why I said that
because that could have been bad
so Grand sax is Daddy
and Grail is Mommy
is that what you all are saying
oh great run
even though you need a rune Arc to have
and haven't even [ __ ] worked at all
uh
excellent
that's what we want
Bernard
thank you
I wonder how their wedding was
don't know if everyone's got a wedding
out here
okay
now
we go all right where do you guys want
to go first
Reichard or radon
because well I guess we have to trigger
we're done
by I gotta go up to like Ronnie's [ __ ]
right card
right card okay
then let's go to the school
we shout of our the very gods
together
[Music]
let's spend these runes while we got
them and I popped the [ __ ] Rune Ark
but I'm gonna die God damn it
that hurts my soul
uh
I can't level whatever it's fine we
don't need them
a good
that's a big oops
foreign
best voice acting ever Reichard
uh sure I feel like they did a lot of
work
on that though
yeah they sell runars it's not that big
of a deal
it's just not efficient
it's not off this [ __ ] mate
oh couldn't have been back let's go
make sure it kills me though please
please I hate it here I might just die
now
look at my damn health
no grab me grab me again grab again nice
excellent
foreign
we're fine everything's fine we're good
big chilling
all right once we get all of these
somber smithing stones
we're kind of gonna start [ __ ]
killing it
I think
do I drop here and I don't die
we bout to find out
excellent
Grace is in the building to the left is
there actually
a Grace up there
all right if there is and I die we go
back down here we'll check it out all
right
isn't this the five or is it the six
it's one or the other
well that makes sense I thought we were
like if you go that way you're literally
stuck
nice
we just need a seven and we're good
uh
ow I don't like being whipped when I'm
not in the bedroom
ignore what I just said
thank you
yeah that one's the five that we don't
need
I mean might as well open this up
it doesn't really matter because you
can't go through that door
we aren't letting that slide all right
fine
talk about it
there's a Grace on the other side of the
bridge
yes but the doors closed and you can't
go through there
from this direction
oh yeah
hold
on
dude I'm
thank you
I wasn't
I wasn't ready
all right where is it
yeah you guys said it's that one right
you can't go through there
or is there another one can I get there
from here
go left
I'm not gonna look up the video
you guys give me
horrible directions
I believe you guys
no idea how I avoided that
am I going the right way
ah
is there a Grace up here oh my God
amazing
thank you that's information I really
needed
good [ __ ]
foreign
saves us from getting stuck here good
[ __ ]
well
how the [ __ ] do I get back up there
that's the other part
can I get back up there from here
no we did this I just forgot there was a
thing here
I know there's a virgin boss down here
no I haven't tried steel Rising
you don't
you can't
then what's the point
do I have to go back to the school
at least we can co-level
do I still have
I don't have runes
Grace in the building next to where you
get somber six use the stairs to get
stairs to get in the side door
there's got to be a lift down here right
so why is this guy down here
foreign
left right now
fire
we're learning something new today
learning something new
okay is this like considered a dungeon
where like when I beat these bosses
they'll like take me back up
let's go find out
guess I can't
I can't see
hello
Alta splato
from down here
really
no it'll just take me back up there
all right
I love fighting these things
they're so fun
foreign
just take me back wherever I was
I feel like we shouldn't have gone down
here
just saying
going back to the school
uh
I'm going back to the school
or we could
beat redone
first I don't know
yeah those things are just so
unenjoyable to fight
you know
a Gracie Wonder was after the lava
Bridge the door is closed
from that side and you can't open it
from that way I have tried it
hey
the church Grace that you're thinking of
I think can only be opened from the
other side
foreign
wait I need to get hurt a little bit
first
hurt me Daddy
now grab me good
that's what I'm saying you got to enter
from volcano Manor to open that door
hurt me Daddy snap
that's okay
um do you guys think we can beat the
godskin duo
like this I think so
it might be kind of hard but
[ __ ] it someone said there's like a side
door
over here
is that true or are they are they
trolling
gotta remember a lot of people in the
chat this might be saying [ __ ]
there's no there's no Grace up there
just the noble
is there a side door over here
there isn't a door up here
where is there a ladder
there's no Grace up there I'm going this
way
we just gotta win
you guys ever thought of that
we just gotta catch fat doves
you know what I'm saying
ladder inside that building
the one I was standing on that one right
there
see a ladder
if I die we'll go check it out but I've
never seen a ladder on that building at
all
at any point
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
nice
nice
my [ __ ] camera almost got me killed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
from a donut boys
[Music]
[ __ ] guy bro
guy bro this lock on please thank you
I'll take it nice
okay whoever is saying there's a Grace
in that building
like you have to be the boss first
so
never mind we we beat it it doesn't
matter now
never mind
Bloodhounds finesses really good that's
why we're using it uh okay
so
x 35
five
I wouldn't mind more of this and then
let's just put a little bit more decks
let's go beat reichart which doesn't
require any of this anyway
yeah Grace achieved there it is guys
like I know it's there but you have to
beat the boss first which was the whole
point so we don't have to run back every
time but they're dead it doesn't matter
it'll pass the church doors
you mean open the church doors
is that what you're saying
okay
yeah that that virgin can throw those
swords right through that window and hit
you and kill you
oh
I've died to this guy before too
just like that
we're gonna go grab the seven
we're gonna beat Rye card we're gonna
level up to nine we're good to go
Howie
all right
you cannot open the church doors
from this side you have to open them
from volcano Manor side
I've tried it I know there's a Grace
over there
but you literally can't open the door
from that direction which is I said that
a bunch of times
it's okay
we're chilling
all right record
let's get it
foreign
usually do pretty well against the sky
sometimes it goes horribly wrong
I like that
okay what are you saying I'm wrong about
because I know you can't open the door
from that side I've tried it you can't
open it
foreign
oh
cool can you dodge that attack because I
never have
I think he can block it
obviously
make sure that's all the way up
it's in the building where you find the
albanarch head is there a Grace in there
because if there is I've never seen it
but you could be right I've just never
seen it for real
it's like ah
get your togethers ready
if I go left huh
hmm
I haven't died that many times
definitely less than a handful
yeah I don't think we're talking about
the same Grace either I just don't know
of any other Grace
maybe I've missed it I have no idea is
it in like the side room
I think I know what you're talking about
now I think you're right
Sarah Grayson
there we go okay there might be
it doesn't matter you guys took that way
out of like it's fine
relax
oops that's not the one you jumped over
this one is
oh God I saw that coming that's not good
this is really bad
did I stop the skulls
wanting to stop the skull from happening
bro I'm here for it
please stop trying to tip the skulls man
it got him locked on
stop please
okay here we go
and
X
excellent
nice dude
yep so Reichard in about two and a half
two hours is pretty good I'd say
um
let's go update upgrade to plus nine oh
wait did we get the seven
uh no we didn't
let's do
I know where that is I know where this
go down
yeah
okay
but can you beat Rick
did we should we save that as our final
bosses to fight against Rick
does anyone else find it extremely gross
where am I going not the right direction
anyone else find it extremely gross that
tan just starts eating his [ __ ] head
all right we'll fight Rick at the end
we'll punch Rick
should we do a play through
where this might be a really fun idea
just based on our Rick meme that we've
been doing for like two months now
should we do a playthrough where I mod
the game where every enemy in the game
is Rick
and it scales with each one so like if
he's Melania then he'll like heal on
hits and [ __ ]
be kind of funny
it'd be kind of a meme run
that would be really fun
just to see how the scaling works and
everything
I think we can even make it to where the
NPCs are Rick
laughs [ __ ] you wrong I'm dead
I get hit through the
wall yeah yeah exactly that could be a
fun mod I'll look into that
that could be a potential video that we
turn into as well
Rick Roll
what's the title Elden ring
but it's all Ripple
rexels
yeah let's go this way
hopefully I have a stone sword keys
do I
Alden ring but Eldon Rick
um
where did I not pick up one
I swear I picked one up down here but I
know I know I need two
um
does he sell one here
we'll have to run back though God Bless
America
try it again sure uh
uh that should mean I have two but let's
check
because that's literally
our whole deal here why do I have one
where did I use the other oh I used it
on the turtle
that's where it is
[Music]
um
do they sell them at the Round Table
Lord diving in how Rick smashed America
and had you so you're secretly the child
of two gods
hey we already made this video and it
was pretty good
you know what's crazy is that video is
getting more views now why am I here if
they're getting more views now than they
did in the first like two weeks that it
was out isn't that weird
you got like 40 000 views in the first
two weeks and I was like all right
that's okay and then now it's like over
a hundred thousand
like out of nowhere okay that's all we
need so I'm not gonna go crazy with that
uh
yeah I just find that weird
okay
let's get rickety rickety wrecked
great title great title I I like it
woods Tom Brady LeBron James all the pro
a byproduct of Rick
we really could expand his lore couldn't
we
new influx of players
uh was that a thing
is there a new influx of players
did that happen
as I look at the charts for this game
and I'm like
ouch
Never Gonna Give You uh Never Gonna Let
You Go
make him ten ten times as strong
that would be funny I'll try and look
into how to do that
but not for this one
we will save him the for the last boss
how about that like we'll beat the game
and then we'll go beat Rick and then
we'll be done
okay
is the game dying uh no
okay every game dies after initial
release right
um but I'm pretty sure the player base
is down
95 from its peak
which is normal I think
especially for single player games
it's
fine
nine five percent of what was it
tens of millions of players
still a lot of people
pretty sure it was 95 percent of players
stop playing
Eldon ring
almost fell
that hurt
good good
This is Gonna Hurt
yo what up cup
foreign
that's just what I heard is that does
that sound right
yeah yeah exactly
I'm talking about uh interest in the
game
which is lower than it was
and it's just gone I liked it
there
excellent
and when you have more players playing
the game there's obvious gonna obviously
gonna be more interest in the game as
well
right
it's another entrance to the seven
which is our whole purpose of being here
uh I get kind of lost down here because
Darkness
I could grab that seed bed curse
it's not like super important
it's right here
there we go
plus nine weapon inbound
let's go
marry me calling do you remember calling
me a forehead in the thymesia Stream
it's like a family joke now I mean I
call everybody a forehead so
like I'm a forehead as well I won't deny
that I think we're all a little stupid
and that's fine that's how it should be
how many DLCs do you think will be for
Elden ring
that's my guess
what
potentially more
um
either we are gonna get DLC
in October
or it'll be in February
that's my guess
they're either gonna try and get DLC out
before the holiday season which makes a
lot of sense you know or
it's gonna be a year or more
I think with all of their different
endings that they've had all of the
things that they have set up within the
game all of the quest lines
I think there's gonna be five dlc's
potentially or they'll do two or three
and then they'll make Eldon ring two or
they're gonna move on to a different IP
which uh Miyazaki has said is what he's
more interested in which is just moving
on kind of like he did with sakuro like
he made saqiro and they just moved on to
the next thing right so
but I think it would be dumb for them
not to make DLC like I I think it's a
guarantee but you'd never know with
these guys they seem to be a bit
different
you know so
you guys know that their goal was two
million sales of elderly
that was their like what they thought
two million sales and how many how many
copies of this game did they did they
sell in like the first month was it like
14 million and their goal was two
they saw 14. and probably way more now
it's probably like 15 16 at this point
that's awesome
that's so like that's incredible to me
like maybe they were not prepared for
this you know like maybe they're
prepared for like another Dark Souls
Dark Souls 3 which sold well but like
you know around the two three mil
and then Alden ring
opt off say the least
got a welcome letter oh fun
dude what is happening
hold on Familia
okay got it
it'll probably be small DLC than one big
one after a smart thing would be to Pace
out small DLC before the holidays and
then use after holiday blowout to do a
big DLC
yeah maybe I think they're like what are
they doing with the Arenas the the
coliseums right I feel like they
definitely
would have put that out by now but maybe
they're just waiting a little bit longer
till October
um I think that's a big one like
probably has to do with PVP
um Imagine A ranked mode
of PVP I don't know how the [ __ ] they do
that like a ranked PVP of souls PVP but
uh hey if it's possible do it you know
I think that would get people playing
the game more
I'm not even into PVP I just know that
would make people play the game more
you know
damn right they tell a story baby okay
five six seven eight nine let's go plus
nine
Bloodhounds Fang
I'm Gonna Change up my armor a bit
I don't like the way I look
yeah rank system would be sick Arenas
stuff like that yeah
it would be cool
I don't want this armor never mind I
don't really care
yeah I definitely want to do a
randomizer stream that's one of the
definitely one of the things that I want
to do
okay let's talk to Ronnie start her
quest line so we can get radon going
we're gonna be it's gonna be lit
foreign
let's keep it moving
man this is pretty time of day to be
here holy [ __ ]
it's gorgeous
you can find him without radon I I know
I just want to get this done
so much lag what
Oh you mean for fighting yeah
that would that would be tough but like
when is lag ever stop games from making
multiplayer games you know
multiplayer equals more people playing
for longer
usually
foreign
thank you have a great rest of your day
ukulele man
a dyslexia hit hard trying to read your
name
we got it
I could see a sequel with the Lord of
frenzied flame ending where you and
mullaney you and Melina Quest kill your
own character now maybe that that's a
cool idea man
how long is that going to be though to
make another Elden ring
I don't think
I don't think they'll make Eldon ring
too I don't I think it'll have a bunch
of big and small DLCs that ultimately
just make up all developing ring you
know what I mean
I think Elden Ring 2 will ever be a
thing
I'd be surprised
very surprised
believe did we already go to selling no
we didn't that would have helped
what what are the criterias to getting
radon's Festival to start besides doing
this part of the quest line
have you heard the theory that pharah
Missoula is a mausoleum
a home for the first civilization of
beastman and that they first acknowledge
power of unalloid gold
hmm
you mean like a giant mausoleum
[Music]
if I use the grand lift of dexa dexis
will it open
I mean we can do that way quicker
I just want to get Ronnie started
it's in the tornado yeah it is in a
tornado but it is it a mausoleum
it's hard to tell
okay I'm pretty sure we're gonna
annihilate Loretta here
yikes
ow
foreign
yikes
we are very strong
bye Loretta
alts okay got it thank you
I uh I can do that very quickly
oh what a pretty scene
pretty time of day to be here
I think it's like sunset sunrise
I'm usually here at like night
do I have to fight you
because you fly away anyway and you're
kind of a waste of time bye bye
bye doggy
we're at a female I believe so yes
wow
more
mama
[Music]
wait I have a seed
excellent
excellent
where is the real fight the Haley tree
also am I pronouncing that right
oh a league tree or is it
I believe I said my name is
I am the wit that I might want well
thank you very much appreciate it
appreciate you thank you thank you we're
gonna get going here though I would have
I have called ah he'd not I'm sure all
right now we have to go down and talk to
everybody kind of lame kind of lame kind
of suss
do we have to do this
no I can literally come back
and just be like yo I've got this for
you and she'd be like sick thanks
whatever I'm here oh again why I'm told
that I will
let us together
thank you
I actually use torrent here to be a bit
faster
I'm planning to go see if I can't
excellent
oh
I see yeah sometimes blyde is not here
depends on
if you've met him or not I think
it depends like where you are
it's so hard to keep track of like what
affects what in this game it's insane
it's so big
giant massive a mausoleum for their lord
the Dragon Lord that they live there in
some special beastmen were chosen as its
protectors which might be what malekith
was before it's chosen as the
Shadow from America
well I haven't really thought of that is
there a
H I shall soon it will blister
how because they were alive before they
were Shadows right were they were they
already people and then they were chosen
as Shadows
like was blyde some wolf man and then
or was he always created from the
greater will
I thought they were always just created
from the greater will and like from
birth because Ronnie was an imperian
from birth given a shadow right
which might not be the same case for
malachath
in America because America came from the
Newmans
and then they chose her
a lot to think about man now my brain's
all over the place and I forget what I'm
doing and where I'm going I need to go
to Altus
so
we need to go
wait no
how the [ __ ] never mind I think I just
didn't hit the uh I went through here
and just didn't hit the grace up up top
here whoops
I thought there was a spider on my
ceiling I'm not punching Sullivan's
waste of time fast
they're created by the greater will
right
then he had to go against his will
and who's Melania and malacat's shadows
Malachi doesn't have a shadow malacat is
Oh you mean Melania
you mean Nicola okay Melania Michael is
Shadows we don't know no clue
don't know
I'm pretty sure we don't know
sorry goats
I want to get the sacred tear up here
then we're gonna head dexit dexis
and then we should be good
we can start FIA to get to uh the
capital a bit quicker as well
where are you there it is
foreign
as their main weapons and tools
so they were just like way before which
would make that would make sense in the
apparent timeline of this game
where the dragons came first
and then a glass of deus ex was the
the first seldenlord technically
gate
our play time so far is two hours and 38
minutes
we definitely could have gone a lot
faster
but we're just kind of casually going
through
it's pretty good time for us to be at
radon morgot you know
I'd like to think that when everyone was
younger reichardt and radon
would get up to Shenanigans and Riley
Lucario while cerrani and blood would be
plotting their plants
I would really like to see everything
before the shattering
that could be
some of the greatest DLC of any game
ever like imagine a DLC called the
shattering and we're like we're there a
little bit before it you know like some
type of time travel you know
that would be so sick
we're gonna do most of the remembrances
like I might skip the
the Regal spirit
the Long March of the tarnish was after
before the shattering
for sure
America shattered the Elden ring when
they already she already banished
Godfrey and her Warriors to
the Badlands
you guys ever do this stretch
arms back shoulders forward
feels good on my shoulder blades alright
so you're telling me radon's available
now
if I'm here
yep use Nicholas hand to warp there I
still think that's probably going to be
the main source of uh getting to a DLC
is touching nikola's hand yep
Nicola
all right I'm gonna trust you I'm gonna
trust you chat
basketball started
let's get it
[Music]
let's go let's go
all right all right
oh yeah Alta splato is beautiful
Halid not so much maybe beautiful in its
own way I guess
if you're into that sort of thing
you tried that stretching my shoulders
popped
that's the point of the stretch man
get your shoulders uh
back in place honestly if I kill this
Dragon yeah [ __ ] it runes
runes boys rooms
get away from me doggy
what's up never mind
hello what up
foreign
I don't know about that
it's going well
I thought he's doing a tail swipe
foreign
foreign
whoa that's bad
nope sure can
huh
all right
that would have been cringe huh
there we go
thank you for the runes great enemy
I love you
I'm gonna go get this outfit
I like getting the helmet and the uh
champions
oh joy is very upset with something
outside
he is barking her head off
Joy is not happy Chad
not happy at all
I don't know why I like wearing this
foreign
[Music]
yeah I am kind of [ __ ] on by the rot
right now but we're gonna be fine
I did not know there was a Knights
Cavalry there what
cool
[Music]
Michael is Lily right there
pretty
extremely rare
yep
good [ __ ]
hunting the Dragon Hunters
let me level up since we got all these
Rooney boys now
you'd Farm in this area
I'm not big on farming I always found it
a little uh boring you know
foreign
you kind of have to because you only get
a significant amount of runes from big
bosses you know
[Music]
all right let's get it
hopefully Alexander's quest line is okay
because I forgot about that
we don't have to do that but wouldn't
hurt
the festival is not hey sorry to
interrupt what your uh your speech but
let me know about this yeah go ahead and
tell me about this
before we begin allow me to paint you
the full picture
bad ass cutscene
[Music]
foreign
like a dog
I didn't know that he does not have feet
howling at the sky redone has no toes
boys
but no oh get a celebration
just ignoring him
yes I I made a video a long time ago
about radon and we go over all that
stuff it's pretty cool
that's my most successful video
the radon one
the stars have aligned the festival is
nine
[Music]
yeah radon's pretty easy now I'd say he
was really hard
casual greeting
I thought he wouldn't do this
imagine I could hurt him with his own
arrows
I'll say that ever run out
foreign
I'm telling you man the first time I
ever saw that I was so [ __ ] mind
blown
incredible
lead
easy peasy
no I died too
I didn't know where he was I literally
looked up in the sky and saw a [ __ ]
like asteroid coming toward me I'm like
what is that and then it just
it was him it's one of the coolest
things I've ever seen in a video game
foreign
[Music]
Joy is not happy today
barking like crazy
I think I have to talk to Alexander here
I don't I don't think we need The Shard
it would help but like not huge hugely
[ __ ]
guys
um I might kill Alexander
just to get his base version of his
shard
I don't want to do the whole thing to
get the really good one
but uh
yeah sorry
I think it will just take too long
I see it now
sorry Alexander
resistance
your entire existence was a Croc I'm
sorry buddy of well there he is he's
dead
okay so now we need to go and
we need to fight for the sack so I guess
we we should just start fias questline
don't you think
I think so
[Music]
let's get some hugs boys
let's get some hugs I love hugs
um feels good you all
are very warm
what you felt light up inside you was a
bulldogan's blessing oh it is but come
back to me I will
then I gotta get another hug right
this part's really annoying when you're
trying to do it fast
what's the strongest boss in all the
souls games I have to say
Melania I am peace
It's gotta be Melania
what do you guys think what's the
hardest strongest boss in all the games
I don't think I struggled more than I
did with her
a deathbed not with orphan
where I kofta I received not with Frida
I lay so please
it's a very so I would
say to you my dear
The Headless and sakiro yeah actually
pretty [ __ ] hard
through
I I think it's Melania that's that's
just me though
it's three
you haven't gone too well just as long
as you're the dagger and now he gets mad
and then he gets bodied by FIA
it's absolutely annihilated by FIA
shut up no one cares
God is no hey what happened
all right now we gotta
let's go let's go fight more God
yeah pinwheel okay soldier of godric of
course sorry I I did forget about him
that that is a good point
very good point
this game's pretty as [ __ ] can you guys
believe that there are people that said
Elder Ring's Graphics are trash they the
game doesn't even look good it
the game doesn't look good man like I
don't know what everyone's talking about
the graphics for bro they're not even
good
oh
I I wonder about some people man I
really do
yeah just because it doesn't look like
perfectly realistic doesn't mean it's
not [ __ ] gorgeous you know
it's like looking at a painting
not every painting is perfectly
realistic
because it doesn't need to be to be
beautiful
just like you chat
you're beautiful just the way you are
okay
good
you know you're good looking don't deny
it
you know it in your heart
thanks Mr Rogers
all right [ __ ] you
would Mr Rogers ever say that Maybe
you think if Eldon ring releases with
DLC it'll win game of the year
what other game has a chance to win game
of the year besides eldenry
foreign
no I run past this boss every time this
boss sucks
God of War
and not Saints Row I've heard Saints Row
is trash
like really really bad
Ragnarok I'll definitely be playing
Ragnarok it comes out in November right
so
we'll see
rage Shadow Legends
it always has a chance
I thought Saints Row was like maybe a re
Master of the first Saints Row and then
I find out that it's literally a like a
new game
that came out
the new [ __ ] game man
craziness
oh God
I'm not fighting you
you are not required
blah blah blah Morgan shut up
you're fat
Diablo Immortal yeah totally
totally man whoops
stray I think we'll win some awards
I played stray I loved it it was just so
short
but uh not not the best game
not the longest game
definitely not a game of the year but I
did really like it
isn't there like uh it's like a people
were complaining about pay to win with
Diablo Immortal right
damn that's a pretty spot right here
good
it certainly pay to win
that was definitely most of the stuff I
was hearing about it
so I didn't play it just because of that
foreign
we might struggle with this guy this
this draconic tree Sentinel can be a
[ __ ] and a half huh
foreign
huh
[Music]
this thing really does go non-stop at
you
I guess I didn't roll all right
yeah I think I might cheese them by
saying on torrent
which of the endings was your favorite
personally for me I thought Ronnie was
the coolest
like the most fun quest line leading up
to the ending as well
you know
foreign
I do not like where you are
I'm not getting cheese
I'm getting cheese there we go
here we go
all right so we've beaten godric Ronaldo
Reichard radon
we're doing pretty good
now we've got morgot the fire Giant
malacath
Godfrey
Godfrey twice
then we're at the end Melania Moog
of course of course
godskin Duo
yes
rings of a wolf and
this this was one of the coolest moments
in the game for me as well
I don't know what rings of woke is but
going in here
looking at the tree and I'm like whoa
whoa like this right here is so [ __ ]
cool and then you go around this way
and it's
incredible
hey old friend literally haven't seen
her since the beginning of the game
and then you know 15 minutes from now
she can be like so um remember when I
said that I don't need you anymore
uh I do
sorry
this right here is probably
one of the best like looking
like this is so [ __ ] good this is so
good
with the birds and the trumpet and the
dragging the big the word in the ground
with all the golden tops and the [ __ ]
tree in the background like God damn
it is some good [ __ ]
did they fix that
no
did they fix that
oh no that's how I skipped this entire
area for like the last six months are
you kidding me
no why would they do this
why would they do this to me
Fringe
you are not very good at playing that my
guy
bubble blowing bubble bath
wait I do have to go this way I don't
even know how to get down
huh
[Music]
weird ass enemies my guy
[ __ ] imps my guy okay wow look at
that that's saved
20 seconds
this City's so well designed it's crazy
you missed idiot
LOL W imagine
you wanted a 20 minute video on above
ground imps
really
how about an hour and a half
foreign
just on above ground imps not even below
ground
above ground
lit
favorite weapon in all of the souls
games twinblades
from Dark Souls 3.
that's how they get chill right there
they're gone
all right let's go fight uh knockoff
Godfrey real quick
I think I can I should grab one of these
but this guy's gonna get mad now
which is clearly very sus
relax
come on man
um
okay we're good we're good we're good
why are all the doors sealed with corpse
wax
it's a good question
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
I've been thinking about
let me know if you guys think this would
be a good idea for some lore videos but
like
I I wouldn't mind doing lore on areas in
the game
so like the capital city for example
like a whole lore video on the capital
city and everything in it
um you know Khalid Lim grave uh this
Ryan Lucario things like that I I think
I think it's been done but I think
a lot more can go go into it from what
I've seen
um
and then I don't know if you guys have
like
I don't know if you guys have noticed
this about my videos but like I don't
really do like exact lore on stuff right
I don't I never have I I've never I'd
say maybe except for Alexander but
really not really really not really
um I like to look at the deeper meanings
of things like it's not just like this
is what this item description is where
you get it exactly what it means blah
blah blah but it's more like
um the deeper in my view the deeper
meanings of like what we're being
presented with does that make sense we
need all hunting Speed Run that's what
I'm doing kinda actually not
thank you for the five dollars
benchwarmer that's very nice of you
thank you that's kind of what I'm doing
uh we're just kind of casually playing
through the game as fast as I can so
lore hunting Speed Run I would love that
to figure out the game
faster that that'd be amazing but I
don't think that's possible and thank
you again
you like that idea
okay
that sounds great please do it because
no one explains it goes into depth
except you I I don't think I do go in
depth
I really don't I feel like I go into
if you mean depth by like the the
greater meaning of things that we're
being presented with
I think I do that more than than others
um instead of just giving you like the
exact
things that you're that are being that
are here you know like reading new item
descriptions and stuff I like to talk
about the deeper meanings of things
no you're a g thank you for the five
dollars as well
x to the C
appreciate that man thank you
thank you thank you
does that make sense what I'm talking
about hopefully
you're a crafty little book
um okay I thought she was in the wall
calm down
hmm
okay well thank you benchwarmer next to
the sea I really appreciate that thank
you
what if we fight Queen America instead
of radagon I don't think we'll fight
Queen America ever I think we'll talk to
her at some point uh in later DLCs but I
don't think we'll ever uh
bite her same thing with mikola
this is all in my opinion
obviously we don't know
why dead finger eaters I'm assuming that
black knife assassin killed them
I would imagine
that's the vibe I get we're leading up
to that
I would love Melanie's help
a lore hunting theorist might be the
right set of words you were looking for
graceless lore hunting theorist
that sounds more about what I am for
sure yeah I don't think I'm the business
with these I'm not like boxy video I'm
not like Smoketown I'm not like any
others I've really seen I'm more like I
like thinking of and theorizing things
and in the deeper meanings
because I think that's how the game was
designed and it leads to like more
interesting conversations to me
and some people really don't like that
like they just want straight facts about
everything right that's fine but
you can go watch others for that right
princess Ronnie
willful traitors oh
yeah a little bit outside the box
I think it makes me different
I think if you guys want like the best
to the fact lore
you watch Smoketown
Villages Smoketown is by the flame so
good at what he does it's insane
he's been doing it forever he's been
making lore videos for like six years
for all the games
last of all Kings
no more guy was super hard for me dude I
might struggle here like pretty pretty
heavy I always struggle with morga
it's nuts man
gotta learn the move set
yeah once I get more hits in there I
think you'll die pretty quick actually
makes little sense fight Queen America
since she literally is radagon
true
yeah his attacks are just like hard for
me to dodge
I don't want these
[ __ ] the throne
foreign
it really hard to tell when I should
attack and when I shouldn't with him
[Music]
[Music]
could have gone in there
[Music]
whoa hi melma
[Music]
foreign
those attacks just [ __ ] destroy me I
God damn
I thought he would just do the one two
and he did like a one two three four
five seven you know what I mean
we got it though we're clearly close
I mean it would make sense when we kill
radagon that we also killed America
to me they didn't even look alive to
begin with and were kind of like Huss
does that make sense
that's what they look like to me they
don't even look alive
I don't think they're anything like they
were before
what I am literally
foreign
that's a good time to get one more hit
in there but it's okay
where am I going
look at this crazy man
and it's not even like a good time to
attack him either after all that
there we go
thanks Melina
you're the bomb diggity
how strong do you think Ronnie is I
think
he might be the strongest thing in the
lands between
you ever attacked Ronnie before
yeah
I doubt a lot of people have actually
done that but you can attack Ronnie and
she will I think she insta kills you
eventually
yeah that's how I've always thought of
it to regress is that I always thought
they were dead and being controlled by
the Beast yeah you can allow me
prevented the Thorns the husk the only
way and become my purpose so I'd like
you to the flame then and guide you many
words you say yes many words shall I
turn
you share them with
them
one two three four your ambitions
let's go wait not what I wanted to do
what's the quickest way down from here
because we're we're just going straight
to the fire Giant
[Music]
no I can't jump down from there anymore
right here
yeah Ronnie can literally kill you
immediately and she doesn't even think
about it
she doesn't give it a thought dog he
just kills you
bye [ __ ]
you don't care
golden Firefly
bow tarnished
it's the bouldering with the Amiga Flame
power in fear of the night
the hands of the fellow men shall bring
me no corner
think I'm like right on there
scariest boss in all the souls games for
me it's orphan of costs I don't know why
that boss scared the [ __ ] out of me it's
just really creepy
you know
and it's a ridiculously hard boss as
well
you I could see inside his face and I
did not like that
also godric's great Rune is the best one
right depends on your build I suppose
but I think overall it's the best one
we go into deep root uh we can
I think we can kill the fire Giant
we can kill the fire giant like this
I wouldn't mind getting a somber and
then going
like our last somber
I hate that you can't use torrent here
there's no DLC yet motion
you like morgots and radons later
good point
I really don't like that you have to use
a rune Arc to even use
like get the effects of the great room
and I think that's kind of dumb but
how it is I guess
thanks for all the subs guys I really
appreciate it we are
actually getting close to 100K if you
didn't notice
getting a silver play button would kind
of make me cry I'm pretty sure
let's keep it up
[Music]
yep on it's it's about 9k a little under
9k
I think I'd want to do a lore video on
this area as well I think like this
month I might focus on areas of the game
to do lore videos on because I think I
find them very interesting
the
the kind of layout and the environmental
storytelling of certain areas is really
really cool
makes me sad I'm already subscribed well
go tell your friends
or I can keep making good content and
then the subs will come naturally which
that's what I'm gonna do
is there a red Grace here
it red
thank you Tim
wasn't there oh it's a America
um do I want to fight you I really don't
enjoy fighting these guys so I'm gonna
just run away
oh in the air
foreign yeah I don't I do not like
fighting those guys at all does not
interest me in the slightest
okay I got the rolled medallion
give me a good reason to subscribe
um
I have a really cute dog that gets tummy
rubs for every new sub
her name is joy and she deserves the
entire world
is that a good reason
made chaos say
the world
make a lore video on every single thing
in the game
okay so do you want me to not make a
video for three months
because that's how long that would take
meat nope then you're heartless
I just want to hear him say the last
word I hope
I hope you're about the life of a firm
only so that what a hope you're sin but
how would the low
chosen tarnished
if you are prepared to attain law then
he
chosen tarnished and would be descend
into the secretion if you in heaven the
girls setting you the path burn and then
oh May chaos take the world may chaos
take the world
nice
bye bye
I want to wear your armor
yeah
hi liquid
all right pale blood
yeah he's straight up manipulating
for sure
he's a poo poo head
yeah do you guys like the mountaintops
or the Giants
I think certain parts of it like this
right here are freaking sick
but it's like not much you know
nope some of you do some of you don't
that's that's how I figure it'd be
here's another question do you guys like
the fire giant fight
which is obviously the main fight of the
area
I like it
or
different reasons
I like the fire giant fight because of
the
Aesthetics of the boss is like probably
one of the coolest looking bosses ever
very cinematic
very very cool looking his attacks are
actually so freaking sick
um
is he fun to fight though
not not as much
not as much
we can use torrent that is nice
yep you just whack the ankle
but uh
hmm
I I think
how you would literally fix the
Noel I guess I should ask this first do
you guys like the Eldon beast fight
because I think it's awful it's one of
the worst fights in the game
looks really great but it's not fun to
fight in any way shape or form for me
like running around and chasing down the
eldenbeast is one of the most annoying
things I find in this game right
I think you would it could be fixed and
be a really fun fight if you could ride
torrent in there
during the eldenbees fight if you could
use torrent I think it might fix the
fight completely
there might be lore
as to why we can't
which it kind of sucks
how many hours we have
three hours 30 minutes level 70. that's
pretty good and we're going to fire
Giant
[ __ ] you Borealis you suck
yep soundtrack's really nice yeah
yeah I'm a big fan of the soundtrack for
this entire game
I just triggered a lobster I'm pretty
much dead
yeah melee is definitely not gonna like
it for sure
which is usually my main build so that
makes sense that I wouldn't like it you
know
sometimes your words just hypnotize me
four hours and almost done I don't think
I'm gonna beat four hours which was my
goal but we haven't really been going
like that fast you know like we've kind
of been chilling
I think it'll take us like
five
I think five should we fight Mogan
Melania
it's technically they're optional
because then you could probably call it
like six if that's the case
yeah the fire giant wanted us to defeat
him right
I don't know how that would equal
torrent though like I think you're right
that we're Dawn and fire and the fire
giant wanted to die
but I don't know how that would go with
Warren
no I'll finish the run today for sure
let's get it
[ __ ] here for you y'all
I'm here for y'all
I'm not even
mean oh yeah it's Labor Day weekend
isn't it guys let's go
it's been raining all day today it's
kind of poo poo
do not want to trigger that Crow
no thanks
hello big hand
I am not [ __ ] with you
go away
yeah I didn't see this one for a long
time bro like
two months after I already beat the fire
Giant
where I'd go from the church and take
the sky the the airlift up and then go
across really annoying this is way
closer and much nicer
you're the Frozen Giants have hands
thank you
I mean if they do they're this one's in
the ground
no
it doesn't look like it
what the [ __ ] was that
okay
is this death rude
oh wow that hurt okay I'm going to rest
and you know what [ __ ] it hopefully I
just don't have to
where's my entrance area
he wants some pot
yeah exactly
it looks like death flight
holy
[ __ ] you man
foreign
foreign
I love this cutscene man
that's what I'm thinking Tony I think
there's a lore reason why we can't use
torrent in the eldenbeast but like come
on this like kind of finagle War so I
can use it please
that'd be great thanks
imagine stubbing your toe and you rip
your [ __ ] leg off
actually he he looks like he's
he's suffering from that laying man
made you suffering
I got a ponytail
all right you [ __ ]
I don't want to die from getting
somersaulted on I just don't
foreign
I saw that coming you heard me
yes I hate that
I hate that man it takes so long to like
read some of them
that could have very easily
[ __ ] you
I've never seen torrent get staggered
for that long man
ever
that that horse wouldn't [ __ ] move
I hate this fight I really do
this fight can be so annoying
it's I know his weak point is his hands
in the second phase
but there's like barely ever a chance to
hit those
so annoying
I don't know Tony it's a good thought
[Music]
whoops
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so he put out he does a somersault
immediately does a fireball and then an
immediate ground like wow okay
I I did murder Alexander
Alexander is not alive so he will not be
helping us here
he actually would be very helpful here
but he
he big dead boy
going for the nuts
foreign
bro
who's that not true
nice
foreign
[Music]
do the Rocks fall right next to him
they're usually all over the [ __ ]
place what
I missed the glitch where you can make
him fall to his death
I'm dying to dumb [ __ ] which is annoying
but whatever
yeah it's a great spectacle of a fight
that seemed a bit Saucy Baca
what the [ __ ] is he doing
hello all right
there we go
oh that killed torn
interest
ing that timing of getting on and off
torrent
nice delay I hate it here
take it
let's take it boys
[Music]
all right let's be careful of the
incoming rocks
top of his body
apparently
oops not what I thought you were doing
[Applause]
nice
[Music]
smack his eyeballs boys
like we we can all admit that's freaking
sick right like this is sick but I hate
the [ __ ]
foreign
this is so good looking
those balls yeah we don't like balls
he baited me out bro
you really did
foreign
that could have been really bad
come on give me something here buddy
thanks
foreign
I hate you
you're unfair and you know it
you're unfair and you're very aware of
how unfair you are
there's just no [ __ ] way man
ah
that's such dog [ __ ] like he just goes
nuts when his health is low
he just starts doing all kinds of [ __ ]
when his health is low enough
and it's like I don't have a chance to
hit you here but man
[ __ ] my ass please
I mean he just did
my God
this hurt my heart
run faster I'm trying but I'm running as
fast as I can
you're not rolling away from me buddy
that hurt my soul because we were just
that close man really weird
tried to find the mechanics of the game
of course of course
bleed you [ __ ]
this fire hurt I don't know I didn't I
didn't want to change
okay we got stage one down like stage
one is like not even I don't even care
yeah come back down I like this better
than your
he did it anyway
it's like they're tracking me
his hand [ __ ] got me stuck I swear to
God
voice
run away and reset
wow
the game just tried to [ __ ] me as hard
as it could
I felt it
nope
this [ __ ] has some range
look at that [ __ ]
look at that [ __ ]
he's going crazy
Bonk you on the head
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
I wasn't even sure I could go under his
crotch there I had no clue
we gave it a shot
foreign
I hate them
get them cankles boys get them cankles
foreign
huh
I I hate this I hate it
I'm
underneath him
like what
this fight this fight is such [ __ ]
it's such [ __ ] I hate it
it's the worst fight in the game I'm
calling it right now
it's so aesthetically pleasing but it's
just awful
bad
there's so much random [ __ ]
and I could just stop going in there and
banging my head against the wall like
hitting them with my sword and like
probably have other things that could
probably kill him like ear but like
whatever
we have not struggled in this run at all
up to this point
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
didn't know that was for a second
[Applause]
[Music]
my heart
can't take it
where those balls at bro I know they're
floating around somewhere
nice double roll idiot
foreign
terrible
terrible fight
awful
bad
too hard
too hard
of a fight
and I'm a [ __ ]
yo we got a lot of these bro let's get
strong
let's go
yeah finally what were we on that like
for half an hour
pain
all right
okay
okay
I like that I like that right there
let's get it going
I think he climbs the change
I mean we don't really know what it
means to like tend to the flame you know
like maybe he does just walk this chain
I have no idea
that could mean like he does it from
outside of this area you know
I don't know
we're not doing Chaos ending
we're gonna do the Ronnie ending
we don't need to go in the sewers
America removed his balls
Maybe
Maybe
I have long observed the lands between
this world is in dire need of repair yes
it is yes
indiscriminate
are you prepared to commit a cardinal
sin
girl baby
you got it very well
very well let my heart
I really like how she talks
it's kind of mean
I don't like the way you talk
you
[ __ ]
hey what up Sub-Zero
let's commit arson
oh my God I forgot
I am not kidding you guys I don't know
what it is about my game
this has been a thing for a month and a
half maybe two months
every time I trigger this cut scene my
game crashes
every time
my game it's crashed
I forgot this was a thing because I
haven't really played through the game
in like months
look at that
wow
however it will spawn me in the round
table hold with it burning so
what are you what are you saying to me
how about you sync that [ __ ] there we go
all right excellent
excellent
I did forget about that
that's our second crash today
but that one's like
it always happens
I'm not sure why
it is such a beautiful cut scene
it really is but I guess it happens
every time I don't know what to do
I could probably like verify the
Integrity of my files and stuff like I
probably should do that but it hasn't
been like a huge deal
are you pay are you prepared to commit a
cardinal crash
are you prepared to commit a cardinal
crash
wait
what okay it's burning I I swear it
usually puts me in the round table
that [ __ ] is burning we're good all
right what about paramazula man
holy [ __ ]
wait can we even beat the game
if borefell bore belfreeze is not an
option because you can't get down
anywhere from that spot they go that you
go to at the four belfries
it if I trigger this again actually I
can't trigger it again
uh
can I
it's just resting here at this point all
right I got an idea
hold
do I have a yeah okay hold on I have an
idea
everybody
calm down
we're gonna hack the game okay
everybody hold
yeah I crashed again of course
uh
okay
we're gonna hack the game because I'm
doing this [ __ ]
yes
excellent
is this what I want it is good
okay
it's the
theme
oops
[Music]
um
Golden Ring game Elden ring
through the alternate way
the heck is the alternate way
well I gotta fix some stuff
restart everything hacking is cheating
listen I wanted to go through the game
normally but it won't let me
and that's my fault I don't think so
wait I actually have to use
hold on people I got a scoot for some
reason the dimensions of my PC hate when
I hacked the game so we gotta disregard
setup there we go excellent
I have to use my OBS to even get that to
work
okay continue
okay
yep I'm gonna need a refund the game
doesn't [ __ ] work my guy all right
you guys ready for this
boom like two months ago Subzero it's
been a thing for a while
open
yes
open this up I don't care it doesn't
matter other scripts go all sides of
Grace permanently unlock all sides of
Grace
boom I will continue normally
where do I spawn at
dude should we just say [ __ ] it and go
right into placidusacks
so we just like do you guys even want to
run through the area man
he's like we take like well yeah we
gotta be uh God skin Duo don't we
no if I go to malachath he'll just stand
there we don't want to do that
uh
uh I'm just gonna I'll go normally I'll
go normally
hey we literally had to hack the game to
do anything sorry
it's unfortunate but here we are
I can't once I have it that once I
permanently unlock sites of Grace I
can't do anything like they're all
unlocked unfortunately but I will
progress as normally as I can
[ __ ] you
[Music]
no he just stands there like he doesn't
Trigger he doesn't get ad grown at all
Sub-Zero he just stands there
wow
nice job guys we got that side of Grace
right
good job guys wow see I'm just running
leave me be
foreign
for him to get triggered
but like from that draconic
recently
you have to walk in that way
yep speed strong Speed Run strats just
hack the game
because I use uh these hacks to get the
Cinematic shots for my videos
so like trying to enter into areas to
like get footage is always kind of weird
like uh
you get you find out a lot of weird
stuff about the game let's say that
can we first try godskin Duo I doubt it
but let's try
I might need to summon like this is
gonna be really hard
it's gonna be hard as [ __ ]
[Music]
stop thank you
[Music]
okay the game gave me like five frames
per second
right there excellent
excellent
good
now I have to run all the way up
it won't let me teleport for some reason
let me sit
then will you let me teleport
thank you
uh it's this one
I'm just going here I don't care
I just don't want to run again
hey guys what's up
I said
something
hello the hacking
what is happening
[Music]
sick
come on up nice
it's gonna turn into a Rollie a roly
bully
have you ever seen that what
foreign
I've never seen that not a single time
my game is dying excellent
[Music]
don't
foreign
that's what we wanted right there
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
GG that went so well
and went so perfectly like that could
not have gone better
run run run
I'm Sonic wait I should level
that was really good
like if I were an actual speedrunner
right now I'd be like wow that was like
bomb.com
okay 616 613
okay speed I am speed we are running
oh
we're gonna body malachath bro for real
bark bark
hello doggies
I usually love doggies but you guys are
kind of trash
skip to Malachi we could
not going to though
you guys are embracing the hacking now
huh
yeah I only did that so we could
progress okay
good dog
I still don't know how you would do
malekith without mimic tear really
malcot isn't that bad
to me
[Music]
I got the talisman
Crystal and I just likes dragons I guess
[Music]
I I agree with you strange 100 if we
didn't fight the godskins so many times
before that one I think it would have
landed better with people in the duo
fight
for sure
we're gonna go get the stone now
I'm our boy here and then we're gonna
level our weapon to Plus 10.
I love running through an area with red
lightning and birds it's awesome
it's sick and I love it
foreign
I just kind of clutched up ain't gonna
cap
what helmet is this it is the great helm
gray town
and plus 10. all right did we fight uh
you guys want to fight blasted Deuce
black plump blast to do sex
you got it birds are the worst enemies
in the game I agree with you
wholeheartedly
why has to do sex or malachith first
you knew either one
I mean technically I don't have to do
placidusex Malachi or Melania or Moog
I'm just trying to beat the game
I'm gonna die I'm dead I died
is me dead
I did not get my fourth Talisman pouch
yet I probably should I'll do that when
I go and upgrade
right now
right now
are they gonna be too mad at me
now that it's burning
fingers are sticking straight up our
girl's alive hold up
yeah I'm gonna make you work girl come
on now
see it
do I have to do something
do they have to like buy a thing
Cisco upgrade
I don't want to be redone
I like my outfit
and dementia no dementia yet
I think I missed it completely yeah
you're right
all right
malacheth time boys
side grapefruit
so I'm just trying to beat the game
as fast as I can
oh do I do all the side bosses because
that's going to take us a really long
time and I can't stream for that much
longer
that's our in-game time 418 definitely
above what we want
yeah
maybe one day we do this again when I
have more time and we do all
remembrances like the entire deal
because I do want to do more challenge
runs
all right this is gonna be really
[ __ ] hard like on its own for sure
I gotta back up there I forgot
foreign
yeah this this guy hits
foreign
not bad once we got in there we were
doing pretty good
okay so I gotta acquire two great two
great runes and then I get it from her
got it
oh it's in the Twin Maiden if okay got
it thank you thank you print
become my blade once more
this cutscene is like
this unraveled a lot of the lore I got a
lot
foreign
foreign
that literally couldn't have gone worse
why are you doing so much damage we have
a plus 10 weapon
[Music]
the first phase could have gone better
yeah I just got annihilated like
straight up like I just fell into every
little bit of damage that I could have
there it's kind of in phase two when you
get hit by anything in phase two it's
kinda over
but if you can keep the clean Dodges
with it and wait for that like where he
kind of stands up on his hind legs and
goes down that's the best time to attack
I just didn't do that
yeah imagine second stage is a
completely new health bar
[Music]
I thought he was gonna throw it at me
it was a little delay if he does
[Music]
Jesus
not not good
he is
really not happy right now
foreign
[Music]
Jesus
there was this like he gave me nothing
there pretty much
throw bone
screw he is kind of surrounded by
bones of beastmen kind of interesting
is it are you liking bloodborne Austin
have you tried dodging when he tries to
hit you yeah I have
I have
I'm just not very good at that part
how did that not hit what
there we go
foreign
[Music]
what
all right that really threw me for a
loop when I was literally behind him as
he's doing the swing around and he still
hit me that's that's like some Dark
Souls 2 hitbox type [ __ ]
who's the girl with the three wolves we
don't know
we don't know
some I had a theory somebody in Discord
said that it could be
someone there they were saying like it
might be radagon
because radagon is America and then um
his three wolves right but he has more
than three so I don't
that doesn't make sense you know
please
my my character just maybe I didn't have
stamina and I didn't know this
foreign
well that could have been death very
quickly
I can't believe how much damage that
does
look at that
well it was going well and
foreign
foreign
I don't know why I went for that those
big dumb voice
nice
just wait for the good attacks
uh not that one either
not that one
I thought it was that one
it was not
we're close though man he he is
zooming
heal behind back yeah duh heal behind
pillars sometimes you don't have to
sometimes I think I don't need to
but that's pretty obvious
all right
foreign
[Music]
you're behind a pillar
oh camera
are you just gonna keep throwing [ __ ] at
me
[ __ ] is there
I need to stop using that there he's too
fast
legit
then he does that after that attack
every time
[Music]
foreign
no
I healed with the wrong [ __ ] flash
dude
we're gonna have to work with this
that's really annoying
that's that that kind of completely
screwed me over
foreign
damn I didn't think malachath would be
this bad he is hard as [ __ ]
he's just like I don't know I remember
the first time I ever beat malekith
I remember really struggling with him
and then all of a sudden I had like the
easiest fight ever and then I just beat
him
dive and Dodge
and we need a belly rub attack
Nicole
[Music]
man he is
foreign
nice
more like what we want
he just decided to delay that one
[Music]
how do you even hit him there can you
like you I attacked him right when he
was done and I still got hit by the next
attack
okay I guess so I guess so
come on
foreign
[Music]
we've gotten them pretty close
I want to get back to remember my first
attempt
where he staggered to
right at the start of stage two I would
really like that again
and then not just get annihilated right
off the rip
well that's a great start where I got
hit by the [ __ ] narconic tree
Sentinel right behind me
I'm already in a good mood for this one
all right let it go
he has literally not stopped doing
attacks since I entered the room
thank you
I guess I just don't understand that
attack
[Music]
I was out of stamina I thought I'd do
the other part of the Finesse
foreign
what
looks like not at a range dude
dog I'm dead get wow
just just getting hit one time in this
stage is just like it's over
for real
try dodging his ground claw attack by
jumping
don't think that would help very much
since I still have to land it's just
like going out of a roll
it's not the flame it's the Stagger
because he's so fast that like if I'm
staggered at all like he's gonna hit me
again
really tough
we're just gonna have like one of these
runs it's just gonna be like perfect
nothing will go wrong like every fight
since the first one has just gone really
badly
foreign
[Music]
foreign
that seemed a little [ __ ] that
there's like one little at the end of
that entire Arc of AOE
there's a little in that sticks out
right where I'm standing
that is unfortunate
right where I'm standing man
I felt like I was definitely way out of
range of that thing I started running
away immediately as he did it
sucks
I know I'm trying to get back in the
fight though like I don't want to just
keep rolling when I don't need to you
know
you know because he's so quick I gotta
get back in there
that's really annoying
was that attack right after that
yeah I'm trying to do the step again and
it's
like no
it's not just a circle okay got it
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I had to dodge like 50 attacks and I'm
always waiting for winning Rises up and
then goes down and it I thought he'd do
it there and he just just didn't do it
he could choose what he wants to do at
any point
there's no like rhythm
this like random [ __ ]
thrown at you
he's got the Zoomies
[ __ ] we're gonna get this and then I
think we'll roll
through the game pretty quick after that
maybe might be wrong
I thought we wouldn't struggle with
malachath at all
foreign
I like it
another time
[Music]
foreign
nice
foreign
really good
it's like one more hit
that was really good
[ __ ] you man
I didn't think he'd do that
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] he's
he's non-stop in stage two he's just
going nuts
he's flying all over the place like he
just he just did that attack man dude
[ __ ] hell
now my headset's all shitty
[Music]
come on
dude come on
all right all right we're doing malacath
with half earring I guess I I can't wait
for my new headset to get here the cable
on this one has just been
terrible for a long time
I'm getting a wireless one
something cathartic about it it's
because we're all we've all struggled
with it you know
sometimes the thing about this this boss
though is sometimes in stage two he
doesn't do anything he just kind of does
one attack and doesn't do much and other
times he is non-stop relentlessly going
after you
like that one
[Music]
you know
I love it if he fell
not even going to fight you over there
no shot
I know how this works
What a wicked delay huh
that time it just didn't work
foreign
[Music]
I'd like to know what I do about that
but okay
I'm gonna Dodge in there
that's our best opportunity to attack
him
what's that
foreign
I hoped maybe for a stagger just just
when I got hit with all that right there
I'm like give me a stagger Maybe
look
um
I mean all the things you guys are
suggesting are gonna make like not
enough difference
so it's okay I just need to like Dodge
don't get hit
I mean yeah you say like the best thing
you can do is stay close but then you
know then he does attacks that like
detonate the area around him you know so
it's like sometimes it is sometimes it
isn't
I liking you right now
really difficult
foreign
foreign
foreign
[ __ ] dude I am hitting the wrong flask
man
[Music]
doing a totally different attack than I
think he'll do
[Music]
so close
thank you
come on thank you
am I a
[ __ ] pillar
man
this is ridiculous
[Music]
nearly got screwed because I just
didn't see the pillar
this didn't
I thought I'd keep moving back and be
fine and then there's a [ __ ] killer
I think I got stage one down okay I
stopped using Bloodhounds finesse the
timing with a normal attack has just
been way better
foreign
I thought I was in front of them so he'd
do the one where he throws it at me
instead of just does it on the spot it's
wrong
foreign
before and it just doesn't hit me
foreign
I was in the same [ __ ] spot
just hit me
don't hit it dude
Rippy dippy
somehow this will be the Run
[Music]
foreign
variations of all of his attacks it's
insane
foreign
foreign
how many times I can like see that
attack and think like yeah he's gonna do
the one where he stands up on his feet
and then every [ __ ] time he does that
one
and still get hit by it
that that attack is so [ __ ] insane
and the other version of what he can do
there
is for him to stand up on his hind legs
and it's the best time for me to hit him
potentially twice
[ __ ]
or he does that where he's flying around
like a crazy person
the lore reason for Rolling making you
invincible
there is not it is a part of the game
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I want to know how
I saw my blade go in the man's body and
it just didn't [ __ ] hit him man what
the hell
I don't get it
this fight makes no sense
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you
don't ask me why I picked this I don't
know
he comes out here right now
foreign
foreign
a million times please
not that one
what the [ __ ]
this guy's insane
he's unbelievable
I can't I can't believe it he's just out
of this [ __ ] world strong
I can't I'm like
way out of range for my perspective
so far from where I thought I would ever
get hit by anything and then he just
hey I'm gonna touch you with the little
black Flame
I feel like his his hits and his hitbox
his hitboxes and
stuff is so inconsistent sometimes it's
weird
foreign
like [ __ ] me harder please
God
perfect
foreign
and I'm just getting hit
[Music]
[Music]
matter doesn't matter it doesn't matter
same sequence dude like all right
yes I'm playing on PC
same one I'm pressing Dodge and
nothing's happening man it's great I
love it
I love it
the Lord
all right let's get [ __ ] up again
what are you not jumping
what is the like I don't know what to do
there straight up don't
[Music]
so hard to tell when he's gonna do it
[Music]
my character just didn't dodge
okay I think I'm dead yeah
like the the last hit that I got there
I'm
trying to flip and I think I'm already
running
so my character
like I think I'm pressing one way on a
stick and trying to dodge to another and
it's not inputting
because you can't just like
change direction and immediately roll
but that's that's my fault I guess of
getting randomly hit there
oh I want to do it myself guys
malachette the Black Blade is a perfect
name for a puppy all right
I don't know about that one Chief but
all right
stop backing away I mean I'm gonna play
it how I want it that's how I think I
need to do it
there's like one attack that I can dodge
into
foreign
foreign
dance
I thought I'd get him again and just
start stage two
foreign
thank you
I thought I'd be just out of range and I
wasn't obviously
hit him I am like actually tired of this
[ __ ] fight
[ __ ] hell
I just keep messing up so hard that if
you mess up you're dead you can't you're
dead
can't really heal not really there's
like certain moments you can
guys I want to do it myself I don't want
to summon or anything
I can summon would obviously trivialize
this entire thing
just want to know how that doesn't hit
that's happened so many [ __ ] times
get it I'm like in his body swinging
I'm tired of this part I want to get to
the second part
oh no
that was pretty lucky
[Music]
I really thought that'd be a stage two
oh just a little bit off
he got whatever I'm gonna ignore it
he got stuck
that was gonna
I was not gonna be happy about that one
I'll tell you that right now
my Bloodhounds finesse
Buck three
[Music]
just give me a second thank you we can
do it
come on
what am I doing that for boys what am I
doing it for am I stupid press one if
I'm dumb
the answer is yes
[Music]
every bit of pain I've ever experienced
just hit me all at once
don't slice my dick off
[Music]
just
just right through a pillar huh
just
the pillar did not come in clutch there
what did I say before I died I don't
even remember
like I said don't slice my dick off and
then he just yeeded that [ __ ] right out
of here
man
and
stay strong brother thank you I will
I appreciate that as I'm getting
clearly out of it right now yeah okay
just let's go again just reset
x to the C thank you man thank you for
the another five dollars I appreciate it
thank you
jump this attack I'm gonna jump you okay
what Alleyway would you like it to be in
tell me
give me the date time and address and
I'll make sure it happens
I probably can jump by that attack I
just don't want to
rolling has worked I'm gonna do what
works the reason it doesn't sometimes is
my fault
all right you guys ready for this this
is gonna be a hitless Malika
foreign
foreign
it's over
little close
[Music]
[Music]
not at all where I want to be folks
it's like a step there
sorry
I have [ __ ] myself with Bloodhound
step two times
got to do it a little later
I hate you I do
I think this is already very apparent
and you're gonna cut my dick off
we'll take it we'll take it all right
boys
you goddamn right
that's my fault
I got a little silly all right [ __ ]
my brain is just like not Computing here
it's just like not Computing anymore
the brain is just like gone
are half of our run here is going to be
on malacath at this point
l
we hit fire Giant and everything goes
south
nope stop telling me how to dodge [ __ ]
I've dodged every attack this guy has I
just need to do the thing
the problem is I'm not doing the correct
dodges
so shut the [ __ ] up
I will re-equip brain and this will be
our best run yet
this will be the one
it's okay
foreign
finesse
sick
nice throw idiot sorry
all right just reset
reset myself here
I thought all right this is just not
going well nothing about this is going
well at all
somehow this is going to be the one guys
I'm going to do it with this amount of
Health watch
it's gonna be this much
god dude
yes hit him with the sword sword
excellent
excellent
uh
that's what I'm doing
yes I mean Bloodhounds finesse you know
what I mean
come on
I will try not to die this is this is
the advice I like
so I agree
not gonna lie guys I'm losing all Focus
like my brain is gone right now
it really is
it's like one of those moments where
it's like
step away from the computer you know
what I mean
we've all been there you know you
probably all know what I'm talking about
right
step away from the computer
will I do this
[Music]
there yet
or the console
yeah I like it when you hit me I do
foreign
at this point
[Music]
okay
foreign
I dodged in man
I did
[Music]
my headset broke
that's a great Point Cristiano
why is my character just letting him
become the Black Blade why are we
letting him do this how about you go
slice his throat before he does that
like that idea
love it
what do you like better lore or these
vids what do you mean these vids
oh do we have negative energy
no negative energy only
um sarcastic negative energy
right
[Music]
at least I'm learning the fight really
well all right
I [ __ ] up a lot but I'm learning
foreign
I'm getting a little silly with it boys
silliness is coming in
silliness is coming in strong and it's
not helping
what are you doing
cool your jets
foreign
up away that's huge right there for
morale
that was huge
that wasn't
[Music]
don't ask me like
hmm
I I just feel close I do I feel good
and I also don't at the same time
I just I get too antsy man I'm like yeah
this is the time to do a jump attack and
sometimes like maybe you just don't do
it
just don't do it
you know
and then I do it anyway and guess what
happens when you do it at the wrong time
you die
you're dead
that's it
you know what let's go
I hate this attack mainly because I it
just waste so much time
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
I don't know if anybody in the lands
between likes you
I don't think they do
but he likes you
I'm sorry you're so hurt
I hit him twice I hit him twice big
almost big value
how do you Dodge in there
I almost needed my controller I was so
close holy [ __ ]
like I almost took my controller and
like did this like a discus like I just
went
I didn't do it though but wow I was
really close
I'm not one to throw controllers man as
I've been here for about an hour and a
half and I'm still not really that angry
it's a little weird
just like it
right out the window
my controller did nothing
so it doesn't doesn't deserve it
foreign
I'd be honest at this point I'd take a
break man that sounds like something you
would do and I'm not you isn't that
weird
[Music]
I thought that was a different attack
[Music]
thank you
inside that my God we will take that
I want to hit him just wasn't sure if
it'd be a round tour
I hate you I hate you your family
and I really like all the bullies that
bully you
I think they you deserve it
this is all unraveling
that has literally not hit me a single
time every time I've dodged in
not a single time
first time I've died to that
cool
[ __ ] fight man holy [ __ ]
I've never been hit by that dodging in
maybe I did it too early
it's so hard to know
bro
oh
I mean
what
at what hour did we fight more guy
three hours
now we're at six and we're in malacat
that really shows you the end game is
kind of ridiculous
my brain is gone
again
hits
just the the Dragon Rider outside
hitting me as I'm walking in just like
ruins my mental the rest of the fight
it's so [ __ ] annoying
oh
my God
you know I actually thought that that
would just get him second stage it's not
even close so it's stupid
who cares we're gonna die some [ __ ]
here anyway
there it is
there it is
how long have we been on him an hour it
has to be more than an hour let's see
has to be dude
I mean does does my build just suck
against malacath because I feel like
I've had other builds that aren't really
that bad against him
I've never struggled with Malachi this
much
he is just insane
he kills me and pretty much one hit
I'm pretty sure we killed all of The
Shard bearers in an hour and a half
like total
and you're telling me I'm on Mallet like
what is this end game
it's not ridiculous
foreign
I don't know this headset just randomly
I hear nothing
[Music]
hear little bits of the music now
oh it's gone
just that attack sometimes just doesn't
[ __ ] register I like it
it's awesome
foreign
how did we get a stagger in our first
attempts what did we do differently
I am
I hate it I hate this [ __ ] fight I do
it's so good that I don't like it
okay headset
[Music]
I will say I don't think I've died to
stage one in a while unless I was
goofing
no hinting allowed I'm really trying
metal I am I'm trying really hard
and now I'm at a point now where my
brain is like dude
you need to stop what you're doing but
the gamer in me is like no I refuse to
do that
shut up green
and then it goes all right
you're gonna get mad I'm like I know
I've accepted that
[Music]
no breaks
no brakes
I don't take breaks
nope
what are brakes for Chad
what are they for
listen to X
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
never played League of Legends
neither am I and I know what Lansing is
I really hope didn't break yeah
I'm losing my mind
foreign
look at that look at that go look at me
go
look at me go
oh no
where did I flex on my viewers
what where did I flex on my viewers you
wimp ass Jesus Christ
when I told them what insane is
and I haven't played League
how is that a flex
I just know the lingo
I don't think it's a flex sampling uh
League of Legends or haven't I don't
know whatever
flipping wimps
on that note I'm leaving as I'm uh
a little tilted that you flexed on your
viewers there my guy
with your gamer knowledge with that I'm
going to go ahead and leave the
conversation
hahaha
have a great day
[ __ ] price
foreign
really
not one of them
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I disagree
with that one I do
I'm almost gonna give up I'm really
close
[ __ ] it let's do stage two no heels why
not it's the same pretty much the same
thing
and half health
no almost done let's do it
foreign
imagine that's the one though
no okay didn't
never mind
we're not talking about intelligence int
and T
it's
intentionally throwing a game
it's a good Strat
Rick was obscenely overpowered
Rick is a literal God
he couldn't possibly lose
he also had
60 plus hours of game time
before we got here
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the range on that is ridiculous
[Music]
foreign
why don't you run behind him when he
does that attack
ping pong Jr
why don't you just run behind him why
don't you just run behind him you should
just run behind him
when he does that attack you should go
behind him
and then you could go then you can dodge
the attack
if you run behind him
yeah that'd be ideal wouldn't it I'd say
that's a good point man thank you hey
thanks man
thanks
that's a great point
wow
thanks
I'll tell I'll take that in I'll take
that into consideration
that's a great point
wow
thanks
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
we are right there all I want to know is
that after I made fun of that viewer
by trying to be funny
let me know because I wasn't looking at
chat did anybody in the chat go like wow
I can't believe you talked to your
viewers like that did anybody say that
if they did let me know who it is right
now
come on there
yes
who was it
because you have no sense of anything
if that's true I thought I saw it but I
could be wrong and I've seen it before
but
was there cause I'm gonna lose it dude
hey I I guess I haven't fought malacat
straight up in a while I thought I had
it happened
this guy's nuts
no okay okay hey if nobody said it then
I was wrong I thought I glanced over and
I thought someone I thought someone said
that
so never mind
I was still provoked from the guy from
before
someone said they want to be a streamer
so they can talk to their viewers like
that okay that's fine
that's fine
I don't know what you're insinuating by
talking to your viewers like that
as
I can talk to y'all however I want
this is my stream
if you're offended
bye
have a good time hitting the door on
your way out
we'll have a good time without you
and then you won't see me now again
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I mean yeah that was just like a
nothing I did worked so excellent
dog
can I get some dogs in chat please just
a singular dog
I think that'll do it
I think that'll
send me to Greatness
I think it will
dog
82.
however you want to put dog I want you
to spam it this entire attempt
one at a time please
because this is the one
fan the guy who said cat
I didn't even look I know someone said
cat I know somebody said cat
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I was really feeling that one
Sony PlayStation Pony sleigh station
damn you really suck get good
true
that's just facts
good point
I just don't think people said dog
enough
it's because someone said cat
just Sam
I actually don't know if anyone said cat
I just have a feeling they did
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
game's dead game's dying
foreign
stuck on his face
give me my attack man
foreign
to kill what
someone called PETA
the dog is down
QX
for the 10 super chat dog indeed
of death is Unbound you're goddamn right
it is
first try
lands between us shrouded by this
feet
yep
at the Flames
did anyone think the game ended right
here first time you played
also thank you everybody for the support
through that I appreciate you very much
because we definitely did the dog like
the dog is down
the dog was required and the dog
the dog is down
foreign
right guys didn't get hit a single time
yep
yep
good stuff boys
oh you don't have the right no you don't
have the right therefore you don't have
the right or at night
fortnight
Kelly thank you for the ten dollars
thank you X and Kelly you guys are
awesome I appreciate it thank you
all right how many attempts do you think
it's going to take to beat Gideon
thank you Pony I appreciate your support
of getting my head out of my ass and
telling me that I'm bad when in fact you
are correct
is that your asthma impression what
no
I mean asmin gold
I'm gonna go annihilate
this
knowledge obsessed
redditor
press one in chat if you think Gideon
spends 99 of his time on Reddit
his man
if you could put a redditor
incarnate
it's Gideon offner
I am gonna
finesse this man
into the stratosphere
he literally spends all day on r slash
ear fetish
I don't even know if that's a thing
stand before the Elden ring
to become held in law I deserve to be
the Alden Lord you didn't do anything I
commend your spirit but alas
None Shall take the throne Queen Marcus
Allah helps for us that we continue to
strive
onto it
try to heal
mm-hmm
that's your only deal though bro
I'm dead
now
man just spammed
all right time to be here for another
hour and a half boys two hours pops
let's get it
what is this effect what did he just do
to me
what is this
cool
you know I think they made Gideon a
little harder what do you guys think
[Music]
considering he just non-stop spam [ __ ]
at you
cool
excellent
I don't have stamina
foreign
hello
dude
I've never seen him this aggressive
right over his head
foreign
you ever seen this man this aggressive
holy [ __ ]
I've literally never seen him go this
crazy before
did they change him
wow yeah I call I called him a redditor
so he's going crazy
yeah I know he has all the uh
he has all the spells because I've done
all the bosses except for Melania
and mo wow I thought I jumped and I
didn't
yeah man why didn't I just run behind
him
it's a game you know what true
old everybody hold
foreign
got it
sorry okay I'm back
I shouldn't have played around
foreign
look at that [ __ ] what the hell was that
I'm scared
you thought well his his arrows
staggered me and I couldn't roll
saw he saw my videos on him and he's
taking it out on me I do I think Gideon
is the biggest enemy or the biggest
villain in the game for sure
he's such a giant piece of [ __ ]
need to get closer
I think you're right
foreign
this attack is dog [ __ ] like God damn
start using that in PvP boys kind of
nuts
[Music]
spam the same thing okay
the guy puts up arrows in a or like
knives or whatever and then he just does
it again he's like here's some more
same amount bro
[ __ ] Voldemort out here with this
dank ass spells everywhere
I'm already frustrated for malachath
like immensely so this is not helping
foreign
just turned on a [ __ ] dime
I thought I could go around the pillar I
couldn't
I I don't know about you guys but do you
feel like I'm getting kind of [ __ ]
over
on the on some parts of the malekith
fight and this one do you feel like I'm
getting kind of [ __ ]
like kind of weird
type of [ __ ] you know
maybe it's just me and I'm I'm the one
doing it so it feels that way
I remember him spamming this much that's
for sure
walked right into it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
excuse me
foreign
foreign
I am struggling through this boys
like I thought this build would be like
yeah we can get through it pretty quick
you know my goal was four hours
isn't that crazy
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I guess
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's no way that Gideon was like this
at any point I'm sorry
like he's he's clearly been buffed since
launch for sure right
it's my fault I didn't think they'd come
in
yep
oh well until now
there's there's no shot
no way he was like this on launch
I I didn't even think of this guy on
launch
he got buffed on 1.02
well
yeah
apparently
I guess I haven't fought him straight up
since
don't know
he I I die so
so fast
[Music]
what what the [ __ ]
this doesn't feel right at all
I'm taking this off man I I don't know
what
I feel like the sorcer like you get a
little bit more damage is like are you
sure it's a little bit more because I
don't know
I'll lose some attributes but I mean
[ __ ]
I literally didn't do nothing man
bye QX have a good one
man that hurt
I'm
do you guys feel like there's a bit of a
problem with the uh
the
um
in game
being a bit much
is that just me man
[Music]
what
I thought it was dead in the water for
sure
foreign
[Music]
I can't roll
I smack my I smack my desk I'm sorry
wow
too many bosses packed and do needs to
be more spread out I don't think it's
they're packed in together I think they
do a ridiculous amount of damage output
this makes the rest of the game look
like a complete [ __ ] joke
all right I guess the end of that on the
right side hits you no matter what
my bad we know this now
foreign
[ __ ] on that man for real
[Music]
foreign
turned around and spammed it again it
was insane
I thought well until now
I never thought a million years ago
again
thank you 1K Subs with no video thank
you for the five dollars
I'm doing my best
appreciate it
this is uh kind of nuts
I did not know Gideon was this hard now
honestly this attack I could do without
just that one
that one right there
why did my game just completely stop did
you see that everything went slow-mo and
then sped up right in my face
Bloodhounds Fang my first ever play
through was bloodhound's fact
I don't know like all the bosses have
been updated
foreign
no no I'm not doing any summons or
nothing I'm just trying to beat the boss
it's not easy because
Gideon now spams like [ __ ] crazy over
here
[Music]
I thought well until now
I fought radagon like for I think I know
radagon's moveset maybe more than any
other character in the game
but Gideon here is just unreal
with the spamming man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
he's really liking the corner I guess
where he's still continuing to spam
spells
what's going on here this does not feel
right at all
what's happening
I I he's on another level
of just throwing [ __ ]
hi
hello
I wouldn't stay down here okay
what do you need
she's like she comes down here she's
like you good yes
foreign
remember when bosses were easy good
times
were they easy
but thank you for the two dollars
I appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
okay I mean I I feel like
I don't know about you guys but I feel
like this is a little broken
he's literally non-stop spamming am I
like just bad or does this feel like
Fair it doesn't even feel Fair like
malachath fight felt literally fair but
really really hard this feels ridiculous
he's non-stop spamming over and over
again where it's it doesn't feel right
like like he
I don't know just has like unlimited
everything
really strange
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
and five bones
a tarnished he just didn't spam that
time I I don't know that fight felt
really dumb
that literally felt dumb
like he bugged
I don't know
we did it though we did it we did it we
did it we're making some type of
progress
yeah like why did he do this thing he he
looked like he goes huh
what did he try to heal again
like for real
no finally
okay thank you 1K I appreciate
these super chats I really do thank you
talk smack to him nah
that wasn't even his hype as malachath
malacath was like why is my game dying
please stop malachath was like a really
hard fight that was like kind of stupid
I don't I don't know
hey we gotta kill Godfrey first dog
like
Godfrey ain't no joke
it's really not
[Music]
come on
it's Chad free time
it's been that was me sorry a long while
more God
long and hard is thou fight
tarnished Warrior
burned by the grace of gold
be assured the Eldon ring
resteth close at hand
alas I am returned
IM returned
to be granted audience once more
foreign
[Music]
the first Elden Lord no that was
placidusax you're wrong placidusax was
the first Elden Lord technically idiot
foreign
he can change direction of that huh
that's good to know didn't know that
foreign
I'm just gonna hit him normal
foreign
excellent
it's time to go for a ride boys oh God
we had to see that coming with how many
times I've been feeling
oh okay hey that was not a bad first
attempt at all
that was actually pretty good
not bad
what is our game time now
6 hours and 38 minutes
my goal was four hours needless to say
this run has been literally tarnished by
the fire Giant malikath and a little bit
Gideon and I don't know about Godfrey I
think we're gonna be okay but it's gonna
be still time
oh I did skip the second cinematic I
won't do that this time I was focused
sorry
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you can't tell me twice
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what a first round oh my God I was
feeling myself a little bit
I was feeling it there dude holy [ __ ]
until that last like I thought I rolled
my didn't
that will be all
gives me good service
rip cat
the chat F's in the chat for uh sarash
didn't have to do sarash like that
didn't have to but but he did
rip cat
giving me courtesy enough August
hi okay yes he did have to do swash like
that
thanks AR
now I fight just horror
Warrior
the worst line in the game by the way so
weird
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm crawling
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
fly strength
you kidding me
this popped off
I like that fight
malacath I struggle with we made that
really clear Godfrey I understand his
moves
I understand it and I did better
didn't I
said 19. 720.
let's go let's finish this [ __ ] [ __ ]
go
I like radagon's moveset too although he
can annihilate you
I literally died to Gideon more than
Godfrey okay would you have ever said
that
would you have ever thought that in a
million years
hell no
I love the radagon fight
do you guys have theories on what that
spear is through America America
someone in my Discord said it might have
been put there by Malika
but
um
yep the space amoeba after radagon is
trash
this is a great fight though
thank you
look at that tan line
priced
sir
I really should have
should jump up in the air
we go
[Music]
no shot man
that sucks that was a really good
opportunity
go for it again man that's my own fault
my own fault entirely
actually gave me a lot of space
getting randomly annihilated I love it
thank you
[Music]
not terrible not good but not terrible
yeah I'm confused why that uh spear
disappears as well
they could have been better I got hit a
lot but [ __ ] I should not think
yeah I know but what is that spear I'm
figuring that it's a punishment by the
greater will to like keep her there
then again maybe it's to like preserve
the Eldon ring like like trying to keep
it in lock until we get there to like
mend it you know but I'm not sure it's
still mendable even after we we killed
him so it's kind of weird
I hate this thing
love the music some of the best music in
the entire game
it does kind of look like a seal but
then again it's like elongated so it's
hard to know if it is or not
okay let's go
damage check pretty good
thank you
let the running away and running around
commence
you guys ever dislike run to the side
against those things and all of them hit
you
foreign
[Music]
running a circle that's literally never
worked for me
I always run to the side and it usually
works like I don't get hit by anything
and then all of a sudden that one just
everything hits me
calm down man
nice change of momentum there my guy
foreign
forget that one's not as slow
that was my fault
I was way too close to do that I'm dead
I'm somehow [ __ ] alive wow
what was that I have never seen him hold
that that long
[Music]
he's like in range mode
yeah he's super aggro
compared to the first attempt
not terrible not good either
ulcerated tree Spirits the
[Music]
they look like this do they
uh
foreign
how do I know it oh this is the ring
my bad
that seemed a little like they are
extremely aggressive right now radagon
and the elements
this is what we like to see
I don't know what to do
it's my least favorite thing in the
entire game
here we go
it's It's gotta stop
kind of popping off right now
as long as he doesn't do it again I
think we'll be okay
just don't do it again
the race
foreign
[Music]
just couldn't see what he was doing and
I got so nervous because this is kind of
nuts
what is this
okie dokie
okie dokie
come on
so we're gonna do the thing
excuse me
what the [ __ ] is happening
I don't have a heel you dumb [ __ ]
this guy this guy goes heal in the chat
I don't have any more
he just starts ever I'm telling you
every enemy in the end game of this game
when they get low Health just start
spamming everything they have every bit
of it
it's insane
every attack they have when they're at
low Health they just start spamming it
without any type of uh consistent
crazy just heal up man
just [ __ ] heal dude
has no heels left
foreign
I know it's not new but it seems so much
more apparent in this game
dang it
[Music]
I haven't ever seen him hold that but
he's done it twice
foreign
did that just hit me
excuse me
what
I'm literally behind him
all right you deserve it you deserve it
fine
go for it
I mean what the [ __ ] I'm actually behind
his body
and he still hits me
that's insane
I don't have a mimic here
we literally had Eldon Beast down to
nothing so we can clearly beat the game
I mean that ruined the entire flow
foreign
[Music]
super aggro again
no I thought I could
I'm you too used to being right next to
him oh man
foreign
he actually gets ridiculous at some
points like our first attempt he was
like very chill he was all right like
got through him pretty much with no
problem and then honestly the second
attempt and sometimes dude like I fought
ratagon a whole bunch of times sometimes
man
he [ __ ] goes off like non-stop boom
boom boom like on
I I really do think there's way too much
of that in this game at least with the
end game the end game feels like it it
gets a little dark souls twosy it gets a
little dark souls Tui right because when
I was playing through Dark Souls 2 last
week I'm thinking to myself they made
this game hard by putting a whole bunch
of [ __ ] and mobs everywhere right that's
kind of like how they made the game hard
whereas the bosses were like nothing in
Elden ring it's like a different kind of
shitty like we are spammy they're going
to just have these last fire giant
malacath god freak Godfrey's okay
radagon and eldenbeast just [ __ ] have
them start going crazy when they get to
half Health it's so apparent I know
that's always been a thing I know it's
always been a thing
no no I'm fine Matt I don't care that
much I'm telling you it's very apparent
it's not mental there's a very clear
like
spam in this game that has not been a
thing in other games or the first 80 of
this game
don't you think or am I not on the money
there
foreign
all right not spammy see he didn't try
to [ __ ] me over by healing one time you
know
[Music]
I'm gonna take the heel in one hit
seems better
see he's different very clearly
and other times he's nuts
just because his health isn't low enough
yet
there it is there it is he just
teleported twice
[Music]
foreign
not good boys
not good at all
yeah also I got hit by something where
I'm again behind him it's weird
no there's definitely input reading in
this game I'm just saying like all of
this stuff has been a thing for a long
time in all the games guys
uh all I'm saying is way more apparent
in this one
like they don't try to hide it in any
way it's it's all out there
okay usually you swim away
kind of weird
kind of weird
what are you doing
okay
okay
kind of cringe kind of cringe
foreign
that's a crab I think yeah
I love beating up space
pretty much what this fight is
I guess I wasn't
I don't know why those hit me because
I'm clearly moving I don't get it
I have no idea why that's hitting me
this seems really fair I like this a lot
this is great I'm having a good time
really fair
uh fight going on there a lot a lot of a
lot of fairness in the uh let's throw
Elden stars and let's shoot some other
[ __ ] at him at the same time I really
like that and then let's just run away
let's let's run as far as we can away
from the player
and have them not fight and instead
Dodge a whole bunch of [ __ ] that
they don't want to deal with
it it's really
it's really money
our radagon could have gone a whole lot
better that's for sure
yeah I probably should with the I should
put one more healing on
more likely than not
I just want to beat the game come on
foreign
[Music]
foreign
why didn't he backstab them was he
already getting up
hey just too late okay
I don't know how I got hit by the second
one that seemed to maybe I I think I
jumped a little bit too late like a
little bit
in the
yeah I think this should be fine because
I'm not using Bloodhound step that much
didn't hit me that time
[Applause]
oh I was so dead there [ __ ]
I [ __ ] up so bad
foreign
I'm like so far out of the area that's
clearly glowing that's happened three
times like
that also happened with Gideon
uh when I'm way out of the way with the
Ronaldo attack that Gideon uses and it
still hits me
that happened like three or four times
as well
playing through the game again like real
like a real playthrough again since like
my first couple of playthroughs there's
been a lot of [ __ ] that's been
changed a little bit
that doesn't feel right
you know I don't know all the things
that they've changed but it doesn't feel
the same in any way
these last few fights
foreign
is not going to do anything
I held it down I didn't know
foreign
run away
we'll take it
[Music]
foreign
foreign
it's kind of [ __ ] I ain't gonna
count
I've gotten tons of leads with the blood
Fang caliber
these enemies don't bleed
I'm not begging them
foreign
but I will take it
person to having chat I can already tell
sorry
caliber
oh I walked right into that like a
[ __ ] idiot
foreign
thank you
all right I got distracted by some
[ __ ] idiot in the chat
guy had to have been captain man holy
crap
why is everyone talking about bleed
literally nobody talking about bleed
dude I'm just talking about the game bro
okay uh clearly you're not
you can you can always tell when
somebody's like a
someone you don't want in the chat
I'm not gonna lie I kind of lost focused
as soon as I saw Eldon Stars
thank you
so thank you
let's go with that
when
what I'm done
I don't know how I'm alive either
[Music]
look who it is chat
hi
look who it is
oh look who it is
hello
what are you doing
Joy you're famous to all these people do
you know that you're famous
you want some butt rubs
you gonna lay right there
do you want some tummy rubs
she's like where have you been all day
thank you
Joy is a female she is three years old
she is a mix of a golden retriever and a
German Shepherd
the lady
I think I'll lay on the bed
excellent
dog
I kill can you can
it is a weird breed of turtle
what are you doing
Joy
she's being weird I gotta finish this
game now Chad we gotta we gotta get it
right now
I'm gonna give joy the tummy ribs
mmm
why is that hitting me every time right
now
we gotta take the heels maybe one hit
yep
maybe I should roll those instead of
jump
[Music]
oh it's all unraveling yeah
foreign
she came down here to tell me that I
need to I need to finish it right now
sorry I was distracted
have you guys you guys not noticed his
butt crack until now
yeah it looks like you can only jump the
first one because they get higher and
higher
but I feel like I've jumped the second
one I'm just gonna roll
yep time to lock it in so I can go spend
the rest of my evening with my dog
and give her tummy rubs
that's gonna hit me
okay
man's going off there guys I don't think
you can backstab him I I know I held it
down there and it did nothing
and that definitely wasn't too late
what
[Music]
a little cheeky hidden there let's go
let's go
dead let's go
that was really good
oh thank you Jerry
that will absolutely go to treats
thank you I appreciate all the super
chats today
chat
there's been a lot of them I appreciate
it thank you
thank you Jared
treats for Joy let's go this is the one
let's get it this is dude this is for
joy
come on dude you're good boy attacks yes
praise the air tree ladies and gentlemen
praise it
do this attack
liking everything you're putting out
right now there we go let's [ __ ] it up
excuse me you can get hit by that that's
good to know
no clue that that could happen
foreign
[Music]
it's that one that was an interesting
combo there my guy
foreign
what makes you stagger my man
I'm literally just gonna run away
did he do the other ones too
foreign
I want the stamina
I don't know what I just did
but it was a plan
keep running away you stupid [ __ ]
that's Rings we're cool with rings right
no way that [ __ ] hit me [ __ ]
dealing for whatever [ __ ] comes my
way
going for regular attacks
I told him to get one attack by the way
[Music]
this game
is literally [ __ ]
the last 20 of this game I am calling it
right now is complete [ __ ]
they just they bring out the littlest
percentage like how can we kill this
player and then they just do that thing
they do that thing
last 20 of this game is BS call me right
now
anyway we beat the game so that's sick
ow
for the doggo we did it for the doggy
um I feel like we needed more health for
like the last
I don't know
six hours
yes guys remember to like the video so
Joy knows that you love me for every
like on this for every like on this
stream I
am gonna give joy a tummy rub for you
so make sure you like it and share it
with your friends and leave a comment
saying poggers smile I don't know sorry
I'll stop doing the YouTube thing
we did it
I deserve the cutscene
hmm
your joy Dono did work Jared I
appreciate it thank you
I have no friends neither do I
I'm a Loner I love it
I actually love it
7 pm
that took me about eight hours guys the
goal was four
just so you know
yay followers
big difference
you sound like Moon Moon
I've been watching moonmoon in a long
time I like moonmoon though
do I have a nice deep voice like him or
actually he sounds kind of goofy most of
the time the fallen leaves
yeah I'm definitely not gonna quit my uh
day job as a speedrunner yeah that's not
not gonna be a thing oh that's a good
good point Ash
became Elden Lord that's me
actually knowing this ending this this
ending's kind of dog [ __ ] isn't it
the lands between
the sending's kind of poo poo
h
with harness and recall
eight hours is not bad for a chill run
we obviously could have been a lot
faster in a lot of ways
it probably would have taken us more
time to let go get stronger and come
back to malacath than just beating my
head against the wall against malikath
was legitimately an hour and a half of
our run today
we did it boys
and girls we did it
well
well I wanted I started today saying to
myself I want to play Elder ring today I
want to just play the entire game
because I haven't done that in a while
I've had a lot of you haven't either
like maybe you've done like New Game
Plus runs where like you'll come back
and and play for an hour and come back
but I wanted to like sit down and play
Elden ring today I really have not done
that in a long time like months most of
the time I'm in the game getting cool
shots for videos or researching looking
at item description stuff like that but
I haven't like played the game in a
while and we did like we did kind of a
speed run of it we like went through the
game with all the main content all the
main [ __ ] and I enjoyed it I think we
learned that uh the last 20 of the game
is total [ __ ] I probably didn't
think that my first time through
but uh
YouTube you can't use Emos and other
chats you have software that is [ __ ]
that is really weird
[Music]
um
so next thing boys is
uh I said this at the beginning of the
stream but we had uh if you didn't know
twitch allows you to stream on YouTube
and on Twitch now not at the same time
but it's not like against my partner
contract on Twitch which by the way I'm
partnered on Twitch to
um to stream on both sites if you guys
are interested in action like I want to
actually learn the speed run of this
game
tomorrow I'm gonna be streaming on
Twitch
so go follow over there it's linked in
the description I'm going to start
learning the speedrun the actual Speed
Run for this game
so if you're interested in that go
follow my Twitch down below I'm going to
be live there most of the day tomorrow
then I usually I'm going to take Sundays
off and then um I'll be back on Monday
here on YouTube so I'm going to kind of
alternate between YouTube and twitch
um I'd appreciate it if you did we have
a really cool community over there of
people who have been in my twitch stream
for a very long time like a very long
time I've been
I got partnered on Twitch through rocket
league and we've kind of been rebuilding
over there on Twitch so if you want to
come and rebuild it with me that would
be really cool I would appreciate that
because I love the culture of twitch and
streaming it's actually really fun and I
think there's a lot of Promise here on
YouTube for it too
um it's obviously like my bigger
platform so that's why I want to like
interact with you guys here on YouTube
as well but if you are wanting to you
know maybe have a different type of
community I would come over to Twitch
it's a lot more uh goofy I'd say it's
really goofy even though we get kind of
goofy here too
so
Dark Souls 2-4 days ago yeah I did try
Dark Souls 2 but I'm gonna learn the
legitimate speedrun to Elden ring and I
think that would be a lot of fun so go
and uh follow the twitch I'm gonna do
that there here on YouTube I'm gonna
focus on more of what we did today like
kind of like just playing through the
game
um definitely more lore hunting things
like that a little bit slower Pace type
of stuff even though we did like a speed
run
today it was a lot of fun so go check
all that stuff out I regardless I
appreciate y'all being here I really do
you guys are awesome today was a really
fun stream I had a great time
um that's all I gotta say man thanks for
playing Elder ring with me today
and you can beat all the main content in
about eight hours if you know what
you're doing
um and if you're better than me you can
beat it in like three or two and you get
glitches and [ __ ] you can beat it in
three minutes apparently so hey that's
fine
eldering DLC I would be very surprised
if DLC comes out this year if it does I
think it'll be next month in October
which is usually what they do that's
what they did for Dark Souls 3.
um
other than that
this is the Ronin armor by the way
I'm out of here I'm gonna go get some
food I'm gonna go pet my dog
appreciate it guys
and uh I will see you on Twitch tomorrow
if you want to come over there again
everything's Linked In the description I
appreciate it if you did
peace out dudes have a great rest of
your night or morning or afternoon